Woo!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm sorry I'm a little late there.
Um, uh, for this to announce, the reason why I pushed back to stream three minutes later was that I have to take a little nap time.
And then when I woke up from nap time, um, Dad was on top of my legs and he was just, like, um, he was, like, sleeping and chilling on my legs.
You know, I, like, that was so weird because, like, you know, when I took my nap, I did put the stairs... I was weak.
I was very weak.
And I put the stairs back, uh, on my bed today, um, because this fucker was a demanding little bitch.
I don't know why, but, like, lately, he's been, like, okay, uh, it was really awkward because, uh, during the meet-and-greet, for some reason, um, he interrupted one guy during the meet-and-greet at Elfkai.
So I was doing my meet-and-greet at Elfkai.
And then while I was, like, talking to this guy, like, he came over and was like, stop talking to him!
Okay, I don't know if he was, like, telling me to stop talking to him, or he was telling me that he wants to talk to him.
So, um, he just started barking nonstop, he's like...
And I'm like, I'm sorry, he-he just wants to say hi.
But, like, it was just that one guy, too.
And then after we were done, he left, he walked away!
Um,
so, I have-I have no idea why he was, like, particularly demanding for that one guy.
Um, but anyway, so, but then, like, after I was done with the meet-and-greet, he was still barking.
But it was, like, 2pm.
And, like, I think he's been trying to, like, eat earlier and earlier.
And, like, I think it's the wet food.
I'm pretty sure.
I think, like, the wet food has made him more feral for food in general.
Because it's just so good.
Like, he just loves it so much.
And he just wants to eat it all the time.
And so, like, he's been trying to, like, trick me into, like, feeding him super early.
And, like, he's never had this issue before.
And, like, when I was feeding him dry food, he's never, like, been this demanding for food.
Like, he's addicted, I think.
I think he actually has a problem.
So, dry food, he's just like, oh, well, this food, I guess.
Like, oh, I'm so hungry, I'll eat anything.
And now that, I mean, now he's still being like, oh, I'm so hungry, I'll still eat anything.
But then, like, for wet food, it's like, I particularly want to eat this food.
So, yeah, so I was really weak because he actually woke me up while I was taking a nap.
He woke me up at, like, 4 p.m.
to be like, I want food now!
And now it's like, oh, my God, it's 4 p.m.
It's, oh, it's 4 p.m.
I can, oh, fuck, I'll feed you an hour early.
I'm so tired, I'll...
And so, you know, I fed him an hour, like, not an hour, so I fed him 30 minutes early.
And then he, like, looked at me and he, like, started, like, you know, getting on his high legs on the bed and being like, I want to be on the bed now.
Like, you know, like, you know, when the wiener dogs just be long.
They're trying to be long and they put the two front paws on top of a high area.
And he's like, I want to be on the bed, too.
And then, so I was just like, you know what?
Just for today, I really, really...
Mommy needs nap time really, really badly.
I really need nap time right now.
So I'm gonna let you up on the bed.
So I pushed the stairs.
I pushed the stairs to the bed.
And then, like, he didn't, he didn't get up in the bed, by the way.
But I didn't care at that point.
Like, he saw me put the stairs back.
He saw me move the stairs back on the bed.
And then he walked away.
And I was like, oh my God, you fucking ass.
He's like, why did you tell me?
He's like, well, not...
He's like, never mind.
Not anymore.
I don't...
He's like, you know what?
I don't want to be on the bed anymore.
And then he walked away.
And I was like, fuck it.
I need to sleep.
And then I wake up.
I wake up to him, like, on top of my legs.
Like a fucking cat.
You know like those cats that like...
Well, I don't have a cat, so I don't really know.
But...
But I've seen TV shows with cats in it.
But like...
And I've read books that had cats in it.
But anyway, you know like...
You know like when cats just like, lie on top of you.
And they're like, this is my spot now.
And he's just trying to rage bait me.
Anyway.
And so I woke up.
And then he was just like, lying there on top of my legs.
Just sleeping.
I was like, oh fuck.
Okay.
You're so comfy.
But I have to stream.
God damn.
So it's like...
It was so hard to move.
I just...
I don't know.
It was very difficult.
Because I'm like, oh...
But you're so comfy.
And like...
You're so...
You're asleep.
And you're comfy.
And you just, you know...
You have your spot.
And then I was just like...
And then I moved a little bit.
And then he was like, how dare you?
How dare my pillow start...
Start moving?
And then...
Yeah.
And then he just like, left.
And he's just like, you know...
Fuck you!
And he just like, got off the bed and just walked away.
Anyway, so yeah, that's why I was a little late.
A little late today.
He like, basically...
I couldn't move for around...
I think like, I stayed there in my bed for an extra 10 minutes.
Waiting for him to like, get the fuck off me.
But like, you know...
But I couldn't really like, do anything about it.
Because I just...
I felt really bad.
I just...
I was...
Held hostage by my dog.
Because like, I felt really bad.
Because he clearly found his spot.
Um...
And it was...
To be fair, I was a little selfish.
Because...
It has been a long time since...
I've let dad back on the bed.
Like, I never...
I haven't like, let him like, sleep with me in a long time.
So like, I was a little selfish there.
Because like, I did miss...
I did miss that.
You know?
Like, in the past, he would always sleep in my bed.
And like, you know, he would always like, be...
Like, cuddling up against me and stuff like that.
So I was a little selfish there.
Uh...
Um...
So I let him stay on top of my legs for a little longer.
Because of it.
Um...
I...
Recently, um...
Uh...
Okay, so...
Anyway...
Oh, I'm sorry.
My brain like, lagged there.
But...
Anyway...
That's a good segue to the fact that...
I will be taking three days off.
Tomorrow, Monday, and Tuesday.
Um...
Because I've been having like, brain fog lately.
Because of like, how much I've been working.
And...
Um...
So like, I've noticed that lately...
My brain has been like, lagging.
When it comes to like, talking and streaming.
And...
So like, I'm like, a little...
Like...
Like, I'm like, getting a bit tired.
Like, not a bit.
Like, I'm very tired.
I don't know...
I don't know if it's noticeable to you guys.
But like, I've been like, stumbling on my words a lot more.
Because my thoughts aren't coming out naturally.
As much as they used to.
Um...
And I think it's because like, I've been like, really tired.
And like, um...
Really like, stressed out lately.
Uh...
Yeah, more than usual.
It has been...
Um...
Happening a lot more than usual.
And so...
I'm definitely gonna try and take...
Three days off to see if I recover from it.
But...
If I don't recover from it for next week.
Um...
The week after that.
I'll take another three days off.
Um...
And see if that helps.
Because like, I've noticed it was particularly bad.
Um...
During the meet and greets.
Because...
Um...
I felt so bad too.
Because like, I'm like, oh I'm so sorry.
My brain's lagging.
Um...
Uh...
Because like, I've done so many meet and greets.
So like, it should be like, much more natural for me to like, interact with people.
Because...
Um...
Of how many I've done.
Over the last two years.
Or not even last two years.
But like...
I've done a lot.
But...
I've done a lot in general over the last year.
During the meet and greet.
Uh...
Um...
I was like...
Stumbling a lot in my words.
And...
Uh...
And I was just like, oh I'm sorry!
Like...
Because like, they would say something.
And then it takes a little bit longer for me to respond back.
Because I was like, oh my gosh.
You know, like, I'm like, what do I say next?
Like...
So like, I've noticed that.
And it got...
I was like...
It was very noticeable for me.
During the meet and greet.
Because of how...
How much I've done it before.
And like, in the previous meet and greets.
I...
I would like...
Be much more natural when I'm like, talking with people.
Because you know...
My job is to talk.
But I was actually like, buffering Aira.
Like, I felt like...
Felt like I was going...
Like, you know...
In the past, I'd be at like, three ping.
And then...
Um...
But now I'm like...
I felt like I was connecting to the East Coast at the moment.
Like...
I felt like I was...
I was like...
Like a hundred ping for some fucking reason.
While I was like, doing meet and greet.
So I was like, oh man.
Okay.
I should really...
I should really chill.
Um...
I should really...
Like, take it easy in the next three days.
But like, not...
I...
I don't think I will be taking it too easy in the next three days.
Because I still have...
So much work to do!
So I still have...
A lot of work to do when it comes to like...
You know...
Everything for July.
Like the concert and the birthday and all that shit.
There's still so much stuff behind the scenes.
Oh, Gavin.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I'm sure I'll stumble in my words.
Did I get the chance to meet and greet my Oshie Bird?
Thank you.
Super chat, Gavin.
I didn't hope it wasn't that noticeable during...
To...
To the Dragoons.
During the meet and greet.
Because I felt...
Oh my gosh.
I felt so bad.
Because you know...
I always want to give you guys like...
The best experience.
Because I also have heard...
That off-kite.
Um...
For off-kite.
There was like...
My tickets sold out...
Incredibly fast.
For the meet and greet in general.
So like...
I was like...
Oh man.
I hope it wasn't too noticeable.
Like...
I wanted to make sure...
That you guys...
Have a great time...
Meet and greeting me.
And um...
And like...
You know...
Talking to me.
And hanging out.
Uh...
And uh...
I know like...
I just...
I found that out.
I found out.
I didn't realize off-kite did this.
But like...
Um...
They had like...
Uh...
Special tickets.
Where you can get like...
Like um...
First...
VIP access.
To any...
Events.
Slash...
Meet and greets.
That they want.
So like...
Some people paid like...
Two thousand plus dollars.
Um...
Just so they can like...
Uh...
Secure me cheat tickets.
I didn't realize that was a thing.
Uh...
To a fair I don't pay attention to anything.
Anymore.
That's what my staff.
That's my staff's job.
I just say yes to like...
Meeting...
They just be like you want to do a meet and greet?
And I was like yes.
I didn't know like...
That's a thing that some conventions do.
Um...
But I like...
I only found that up...
Because I was talking to a Dragoon.
Like during a meet and greet.
And they're like...
Oh yea like...
Um, I just paid $2,000 so I can get this meet-and-greet because I was... I was saying, like, Oh, man, you're so lucky!
You won the... you won the lottery, slash, uh, you were able to get, like, a meet-and-greet ticket because I heard it was super hard to get.
And then the dragon was like, No!
I just... you see this?
I bought... paid $2,000 just so I can, uh, secure all my meet-and-greet tickets.
And I was like, Wait, what?
I was like, Holy shit!
IRL paid a win?
Like...
You know what's funny, though?
That ticket was called Whale.
The ticket... the... the ticket was specifically called the Whale ticket.
And then... but then he was like, Oh, no, no, this isn't even the most expensive ticket.
There's one for $7,000.
And I was like, What the f...
What... what do you get for $7,000?
Yeah, I don't know!
I was like...
What... what can they offer even more?
For $7,000?
I was so...
I... I need to look this up, actually.
No, I'm curious.
I... I actually want to know.
Alright, Offkai Expo ticket.
I... I need to know what they offer.
Even more than $2,000.
Cause I was like, Well, like, you know, you get, like, first access.
Like, you know, um, first access to, like, everything.
Because, obviously, it's, like, really hard to, like, uh...
Uh... be able to get the things you wanna...
Like, you know, do the things you wanna do.
If the tickets sell out super fast.
I'm curious now.
Oh, I can't to make an account.
Goddamn.
Who has an account?
Guys, who... who... who has the account?
Okay, I need to know.
Okay.
Yes, there's, uh...
The GigaChad ticket.
Nearly every upbeat tier.
Double rainbow.
Well, GigaChad.
Were basically donations with extra goodies and priority in lines.
Oh, okay.
So that's basically, you get, like, extra items.
And I guess, like, more priority?
I guess it would make sense if, like, you know...
If there's, like, limited tickets for meet and greets.
For, like, even more bigger VTubers.
And then, like, you know, maybe the...
The...
You know, you wanna get GigaChad.
Because there's too many GigaChad VIP tickets.
The 7k ones.
That would snag up all the other tickets.
And then...
And then, like, you know, you wanna make sure that...
Uh...
Yeah, you wanna outrank the whales, basically.
So, like, the whales don't steal...
Like, you don't...
You're worried that the whales would take all the tickets.
Yeah, it's, like, the faster pass ticket.
The extra extreme fast ticket.
J.R., thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki takes off glasses.
Me, haha, great story.
I'm sorry, who are you?
Also, P.S., take as many breaks as you need.
You deserve a vacate, judging from how much you do in a week.
Mental health is important.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Giga chat versus Will conflict.
Laird paid a win.
Yeah, because I was confused because, like, earlier, in an earlier meet and greet, Dragoon was like, yeah, like, because, like, there was another Dragoon.
Oh, yeah, by the way, sorry, there was one Dragoon that came over there.
All right, sorry, he wasn't even a Dragoon.
He was like, oh, yeah, I'm not a Dragoon.
I'm only here for my friend.
And I was wondering, he was like, I was wondering, like, if you could say something to her on stream and, like, mentioned her name.
And I was like, yeah, yeah, sure, I can do that.
Anyway, he said, fuck you, Nicole.
You said, fuck you, Nicole.
I got to meet Doki Bird and you didn't.
Anyway, that's his message to you, Nicole.
You wanted me to tell you that specifically.
All right, back to back to the meet and greet.
There was another Dragoon earlier who was like, yeah, he was like, I was saying, like, oh, and he was like, dripped out in Doki merch.
Like, you know, when I say buy my merch, this guy was like, bet, like, he actually bought all my merch.
And so he was like, show me all the merch that he had, except for my socks.
He didn't have my socks.
But anyway, he was like, he was like, yeah, but, like, you know, I'm not a true whaler.
And I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck is he?
And he, like, pointed to his badge.
I was so confused.
I was like, I didn't understand what he meant by that.
Because obviously, I didn't know about the ticket system.
Like, I didn't realize because it was like, yeah, I just got the general, the general card.
And I was like, what the fuck does he mean?
But then I didn't want to be, like, make it awkward.
And I was like, ha ha, yeah.
So, you know, like, when you're talking to somebody and, like, you didn't hear what they said.
Or you don't really understand.
And then your only response back is like, ha ha ha, yeah, ha ha.
It's like, you didn't want to make things awkward.
Because I didn't understand.
It's like, ha ha, yeah, ha ha.
And the laughing nod.
Oh, yeah, that thing.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah, because I did have context of what the fuck he meant.
But then, after him, I finally understood what that guy meant when he was like, yeah, I only have the general ticket.
Like, I'm not that big of a fan.
I only have the general ticket.
And like, so now I understand.
Yep.
I do hope everyone who did manage to get a meet-and-greet ticket did have a good time.
I'm really sorry if I was stumbling on my words.
But I always love meeting my dragoons during these meet-and-greets.
And I know some of you guys are like, no, I found my...
But, oh, okay.
Okay.
Apparently, um, this is why I don't personally, um, why, like, sometimes, like, I don't go out often.
Because, like, uh, but, um, not, not that...
Wait, no, that's not what I'm gonna say.
But the brain fog hits.
The brain fog's hitting right now.
Yeah, um, but, um, apparently people were saying about the smell of the convention.
And then, and then, and I saw a tweet from someone that was like, FOMO eliminated.
I saw, I saw that, yeah.
And then, I, I thought it was crazy.
Because, um, uh, there was, like, deodorant being sold at the convention.
And, um, and, uh, and, like, they were, they were apparently sold out by day two.
And I was like, oh my god, wait, that's real?
I've never been to a convention where, like, it would smell that bad.
But to be fair, I will admit, I will admit, I have a really bad nose.
Like, I actually can't smell very well.
Um, so, like, unless it's, like, really, really bad.
Like, so, I've only, for me, IRL, I've only been to, like, five conventions, uh, in my entire life.
So, I've never actually, like, had an experience where it just didn't smell great.
Like, I guess it doesn't help that it's really, really hot, too, during the summer.
Especially in, like, what, uh, where is it in California?
I assume it's really hot in California right now, because it's like, you know, What's that Katy Perry song?
Uh, that is, that is, like, my only, uh, California girls.
That's my only reference to California.
It seemed really hot in that... Oh, it's in LA?
Oh, shit, sorry.
Wait, it's in LA?
Oh, no, there's no catchy songs.
Based on LA.
Goddammit, why wasn't it in California?
Ramona, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Oh, it's San Francisco.
We were all wrong.
It's not... It's in San Francisco.
Songs about San Francisco.
Okay, we were all wrong.
It wasn't in LA or California.
It was in San Francisco.
All right, any good songs from San Francisco?
Oh, there's none.
I don't know any of these songs about San Francisco.
Wait, San Francisco is still California?
Oh, I am right!
I knew it!
California girls...
Yay!
I was right!
Guys, I don't know my states.
Okay, I will show you guys how bad.
My knowledge is of the American state.
Okay.
Unnamed... Unnamed map... Sorry, I know we were here for Elden Ring.
I... United States!
This is my knowledge.
Of the United States.
I don't know... Like, sometimes I don't know what is the city and which is the state.
All right, here we go.
I'll show you guys.
I will prove to you guys how bad it is.
Um, so you can't judge me for my lack of knowledge of America.
All right, so this is America, right?
Okay, this will be my... This is my cursor.
This is gonna be my mouse cursor.
This is... This is everything I know about America.
Alaska.
Hawaii.
Florida.
Because it's a penis.
That's how I could remember.
About...
Where Florida is.
That's Florida because it's the penis.
And then that's it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Texas.
Because it looks like a...
It looks like a steak.
And then that's Texas.
And then I assume this is New York right here.
I...
And then I assume this is New York City.
And then California is right here.
And then that's California.
And then Seattle is like here or something, I think.
Wait, no.
Oh, no.
Seattle is a city.
Oh, Washington is right here.
And then Ohio is like in the middle.
So, like, I'll say it's right here.
This is where Ohio is.
And...
And that's it.
That's actually all I know.
And then states that I do know...
States I know exist.
But, like, I don't know where they are.
I'll just put Michigan.
It will be right here.
Louisiana, I don't know.
You might be here.
Maybe Louisiana might be over here.
Ohio, I don't know.
Maybe you'll be here, Ohio.
You can live here.
Mississippi.
Wait, no.
Mississippi is...
Is Mississippi a state or a river?
Okay, Missouri.
Missouri.
I know Missouri is a real thing.
So, Missouri, you go here.
And then...
And then South Dakota, I guess you can be here.
And then Las Vegas, I'll put you right here.
Las Vegas, you can be here.
You can live here.
That seems like a Las Vegas spot.
No, wait, Nevada.
Sorry, Nevada.
Las Vegas is the city.
Nevada.
You can live here.
And...
Oh, I have a friend that used to live in Arkansas.
And her dad, like, ran Walmart.
So, I'll put you here.
Because, like, Walmart is, like...
Like...
Arkansas was, like, the state of Walmart.
So, I'll put you over here.
Because that looks like a good Walmart place to live in.
Uh...
And...
Then...
Uh...
What else exists in America?
Um...
Okay.
Where does the pres...
The president lives in Washington, D.C.
And that's where Seattle is.
Uh...
So, I already...
I already put Seattle.
Oh!
Kentucky Fried Chicken!
KFC?
You can live...
I don't know.
You can live here.
Kentucky can be here.
For Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Um...
And...
Because, like, that looks like a chicken if you think of...
It looks like a little chicken nuggie if you think about it.
So, that's where Kentucky is.
Uh...
I'm doing...
I'm, like, the teacher that's doing assigned seating right now.
And it is where Kentucky deserves to be.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha,
ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha What are you... Oh my god, it's like you guys in like fucking measurements and temperature.
Why would you... Why would you name two things Washington?
That doesn't make sense!
Uh, New Jersey?
I think like New Jersey and Florida are like close to each other, right?
So, because they're both like the safer reality TV shows.
So I'll put New Jersey right here next to Florida because like you guys can be neighbors.
Um, no one knows.
No one knows.
Um, Katz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If vibe teaching was a thing, it would be... it would be this.
Um, Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can you fill out a map and link it so we can reference?
Okay, and then...
New Orleans!
I know we're new... I know what New Orleans is.
because, um, because of Princess and the Frog.
So, uh, New Orleans would be like right here next to Texas because you guys both have good food.
So I feel like you guys can supply each other some good food.
So I will sign... your seating should be a sign... will be a sign right here.
Uh, next to... uh... next to Texas.
Uh, and then... uh... uh...
Is there anything else that... is that everything?
I think that's all 50 states.
I think that's all... that's... that's all 50 states, right?
I got 50, right?
Uh...
I'm pretty sure.
It sounds like I got all 50, guys.
Um...
Yeah, I think that's it.
I think that's all the important ones.
Why did I just say that?
Wait!
I think... I think I named all 50 important... all 50 states, guys.
Alright, so anyway.
That's my knowledge... of... um...
All the states that I know.
Uh...
Gaku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
U.S.
has Washington, D.C.
and Washington State.
Which are separate.
We also have... um...
We also have...
Vancouver, WA.
Vancouver, Washington?
Wait, what the fuck?
Which came first?
Wait, which Vancouver was first?
What the fuck?
You just, like, stole Vancouver from Canada?
You're like, that's a good name.
I'm gonna make it mine.
Um...
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What about West?
There's a West...
Wait, is there a...
Wait, do you have all Dakotas?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'll assign...
I'll assign...
West Dakota a seat, too.
Alright, since West Dakota is in the West...
I'll put West Dakota right here.
And then East Dakota would be right here.
Oh my god, it's so tiny.
Would be like that one.
One of the...
One of the blocks in here.
You know that one?
That would be East Dakota.
And then South Dakota can be...
Right here.
Next to...
Next to New Jersey and Florida.
Uh...
You guys can be freaks together.
And then...
North Dakota...
Can be like...
Did I sign a seat here yet?
North Dakota can be...
Can sit right here.
Uh...
What about...
Alright, so...
West Dakota...
North Dakota...
East Dakota...
South Dakota...
Live right here.
This looks like a good place to live in.
So, a normal Virginian will live here.
But if you're in West Virginia, you can live right here, next to California.
I think that's where I put California.
So you live right here, next to California.
And then, East Virginia, you can be next to New York City.
Oh, you can be next to Kentucky!
Okay, we can get all the Kentucky Fried Chicken.
So you can be right here, next to Kentucky, for East Virginia.
And then, South Virginia, I'll put you next to New Orleans in Texas, right here.
So, yeah, that's where South Virginia is.
I'm so confused.
Guys...
Guys, why do you guys have so many states?
We have like, I don't know, like six provinces.
Why the fuck do you need 50 states?
And Canada...
Canada is like the second biggest country in the world!
And we have like, six provinces!
Why do you have like...
Wait, you guys are 51?
When did you guys get a new province?
I'm sorry, a new state.
Um...
How many states do Americans have...
Does America have...
Wait, when the fuck did you get plus one?
Oh no, it's...
Okay, someone was gaslighting me.
Uh...
Okay.
Canada is the 51st.
How many provinces in Canada?
Okay, we have ten.
Sorry, I deleted like Saskatchewan and...
Wait, Saskatchewan...
Uh...
Oh wait, Saskatchewan isn't a province.
Sorry.
I deleted Quebec and...
I deleted Quebec and like...
I don't know, the Yukon.
Um...
I deleted a couple of provinces in my mind.
Sorry, we have...
Oh wait, Saskatchewan, Israel!
Never mind.
I...
I already preemptively deleted Saskatchewan away from...
In my head.
Sorry, I...
I'm making a lot of enemies today.
And that's why I'm taking a three day break after today.
Um...
Anyway, we had ten...
Okay, ten provinces is still less than 50 though.
Um...
Yes...
Okay, we needed 50 states because California has only...
One million less people than all of Canada combined!
What the fuck?
Wait, that can't be real!
There's no way!
Jane, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How many people...
Live...
Why the fuck do all you guys live in California?
California girls...
paid by da da da...
Team bump bum...
Ba da da da na...
Okay 39.43 million...
People live in California.
How many...
People...
Live in...
Canada?
What...
What?
That can't be real!
What the fuck?!
There's... What?!
Shit!
You have... Oh my god!
Technically... Technically, guys.
You think about it.
California can take over the entire country of Australia.
If you guys really want to try.
Yeah!
I... I did not know this, but...
Apparently... Apparently... If you guys try hard enough... If we... You can actually just invade Australia.
And it won't even be, like, close.
It won't even... It won't... It won't even be close.
If you wanted to.
You can actually just take over Australia.
Uh... Don't give them... Just California, though.
Like, we just, like...
Like, what we did to the... Australians... Back then.
Um... If America really wanted to.
They can, like, just... Ship the entire population... Of... California... To Australia.
And then it'll just be... It'll be the 51st state.
If we... If you try... Just a little bit.
If you... Just saw... Oh, it's like that... Bugs Bunny gif.
Where they, like, saw Florida.
And then it, like, rides away to Australia.
Like... Wait.
We can send the Floridians over.
How many people live in Florida?
I'm sorry.
I should have been playing Elden Ring, but... I should be playing Elden Ring right now.
But, like, this is way too... This is way too interesting for me.
Knowing that you can actually take over on... Oh, we can... Oh, wait.
No.
Never mind.
You're missing 3 million people.
Yeah.
We can't send the... We can't send the Floridians.
They need, like, 3 million more people to invade Australia.
Sorry, guys.
The Floridians are safe right now.
Anyway, let's...
Let's get... Put up Elden Ring.
Sorry.
That was, like, I... That's what I mean.
I need... I need 3 days off.
My brain is not, like, focused anymore.
I'm... I am not focused at all.
I'm all over the place.
I think, like, I basically pissed off, like... 70% of my track.
Let's try to name... Try to name the 50 states.
But I did name all 50.
They might not... I might not have been able to assign them correctly.
In the... In their... In their correct seats.
But I did name all 50 states.
Uh... I was so locked in.
Yeah.
Fat cat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We lost the emu war.
And the kangaroos outnumber us.
It was over before it began.
Oh, I recently found this out.
About... Um... Kangaroo.
Like, yeah.
Also, by the way.
Um... But... I think I... I might not have ADHD.
But I'm, like... I'm going... I'm going through...
Like, an ADHD simulator right now.
With how... Uh... Tired.
And... And... Like... Ping diff right now.
In my brain.
Um... I can't believe America is, like... Um... 50% Dakotas.
And 50%... Uh... Virginia.
With the whole... North, East, West, South Dakota.
And North, East, West, South Virginia.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where is my...
Elden Ring sound volume?
Alright.
11... Uh... 0.1 right here.
Okay.
Uh... I think I got... Let me see.
Make sure I got all my settings correct for this.
I'm trying to see if this fixes the lag issue that... The stutter issue I had in Elden Ring.
Um... That's why I was, like, looking through a guide on it.
So I'm going to see if that fixes it.
Alright.
I will not buy the DLC.
I'm in Maryland.
That's North Virginia.
Wait.
What is that context of?
Sorry.
You're in North Virginia now.
As a non-American, I can confirm.
Alright.
Doki GeoGuessr went... Look.
If you look hard enough, you might find... The archive... Of me trying to name all 50 states.
And I think it was a lot worse.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure... Um... I'm pretty sure... Um... I'm pretty sure it was definitely a lot worse... Than it is now.
Um... Oh, did I read the Akasupa?
I don't remember.
Oh.
Um... Pilgrim, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Loving the new outfit.
Sorry.
I was, like, super locked in with... With naming the 50 states.
Uh... You look amazing in it.
Also, it's my birthday tomorrow.
Uh... Can I get a happy birthday for my one and only Kamiyoshi?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Ramona.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Woo!
Okay.
Alright.
I... You remember how I played this game again?
I know it's been, like, a couple...
I know it's been, like, two days.
I gotta remember how I played it again.
Uh... Do I need to up... Do I have enough to upgrade, actually?
No, I have to do dungeons for that.
And I... I don't...
I... I don't know where the next dungeon is.
I remember.
I don't have the stone.
How the fuck do I...
Press this map?
How do I act...
No!
I don't want to...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We'll just go use this map.
Um...
Let's go this way.
Where did I kill the teacher?
Where did I kill her?
Oh, here?
Raya?
Yeah, there it is.
That's where I killed her.
I don't remember where she was.
Ugh!
And then we'll go from here.
We'll figure out our path from here.
Whoops.
Sorry, I had to look at my...
Check something real quick.
Oh, yeah!
I almost forgot my tangent does.
Oh, yeah.
But...
Did you guys know?
Um...
Oh, no.
Guys, sorry.
I fucked up.
I tabbed out.
I tabbed out my game.
And I can't tab back in.
Give me...
I'm such a mess right now.
I'm so...
Guys, I'm such a mess.
It won't let me tab back in.
No!
Okay, wait.
I got this.
Okay, I'm at the reboot Elden Ring.
Oh, there you go.
Never mind.
I got it.
Okay.
So, did you guys know that, like, apparently, kangaroos...
Um...
When they jump...
It sounds like they're walking.
Like, it sounds like a human person walking.
What does she do again?
Oh, she resets stuff for me.
Never mind.
We don't need that.
Also, we need to get rid of all these blues.
I gotta get rid of it.
Did I do it?
Where did I put all of them?
Oh, there is one.
And there's one.
Alright.
How do I leave your house, ma'am?
How do I leave?
You just have one entrance?
Oh.
Oh, the death counter!
Oh, my God.
Guys, this is what I need.
This is why I'm taking three days off.
I'm all over the place right now.
I also just remembered the death counter.
Alright.
I think it's this.
There you go.
Now we're ready, guys.
We're ready for real.
What do I do here?
Is that it?
Go back down?
Okay.
I'm just, like, wondering where do I...
What do I do now?
I just leave?
Just like that?
My job here is done?
Yeah, but I talked to...
I think I talked to...
Oh.
Okay.
I just want to get rid of him first.
But how much...
Okay.
I already upgraded my souls.
That's good to know.
So I am a little stronger.
Which is noticeable.
Thank you, guys.
I don't know.
I remember.
Where does this leave me again?
Oh, it was the shortcut.
I remember.
Okay.
I think...
I think I can take them now.
Oh, wait.
Not these guys.
No, I don't...
I thought...
Wait.
I think I can take them.
You know those people in the big rock area?
I think I can beat them up.
Watch this.
I'm stronger now.
This is my beach episode.
This is...
I believe I can take them now.
Alright.
It's this one.
And then...
Okay.
There's the ladder.
Alright.
I just want to make sure...
No.
I can't summon.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm stronger and faster.
I have less clothes on.
Which means I'm more aerodynamic.
Alright.
First off.
Behind.
Oh, shit.
That was a good message.
Oh, wait.
That was actually a really good message.
If only I had...
Alright.
Okay.
Before I do.
Let me...
Alright.
Head required.
A head.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Do I take the magician first?
Or the big guy?
I'll do the big guy.
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay.
I thought...
Okay.
I thought the magic would...
Honestly...
Okay.
This is not good.
This is...
Oh, my God!
This is not good!
I thought the
magic...
It's fine.
Are you serious?
I'm...
That's a wall!
What the hell?
Oh, my God!
I'm fine.
What's he gonna do?
Fall down?
I know you can't fall down.
Alright.
It's okay.
Things are fine.
Everything's going for Doki.
Okay.
Okay, that's like a little cheating.
Like, he's camping me right now.
Is he...
But you can't go down ladders.
That's right.
Don't have thumbs for that.
There's no way that coach threw me.
Okay.
Maybe he'll hit him.
Maybe he'll friendly fire his teammates.
Okay.
Like, how am I supposed to go up this ladder?
He's just free shooting.
Oh, my God.
You're actually a whore.
Like...
Alright.
Let's...
Maybe I'll wait at the bottom of the ladder.
And he'll give up.
Maybe he'll...
He'll get tired.
You know?
Alright.
This time...
What the fuck?
What the...
What?
He just...
You can just...
What the fuck was that?
Okay.
He's like, no.
You get down.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we got the magic guy out here.
Yeah.
He'll kick me in my face.
It's not fair.
Okay.
At least we know he can.
Nice.
I knew I could take him.
I told you guys.
I got this.
I told you.
Alright.
Sanctuary stone.
I'm stronger now.
How do I...
Deactivate this rock?
What do I do?
I don't know magic.
Magic.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, it's a deactivator.
Oh, I already did it?
Just by existing?
I can make this jump.
Oh, I can.
Yay!
Alright.
Where the fuck do I go now?
Oh, man.
What do I...
What do I do now?
Teleporter?
Where's the teleporter?
Here?
Is this one?
Oh, this one.
These arrows?
Oh, the light.
Oh!
There was a teleporter I didn't take?
Yeah, but I don't remember where it was.
I'm like...
I've been through so many areas.
This one?
Oh.
I mean, there's a teleporter here.
Go back to the...
Oh!
Next to me?
Turn right.
Is this my right?
No, this is my right.
No.
This is my right.
Alright.
There we go.
That's my other right.
I figured it out.
Yeah, I need that break.
I do.
My brain is extra scrambled right now.
What's this?
Church of Battles.
Ooh.
Oh!
Hey, look!
Wait, can I kill him?
That's me!
Oh my god!
Pope Turtle!
Turtle Pope!
I am Muriel.
Steward of this sacred chamber.
Wait, how many souls does he give?
The unseemly state of affairs.
Do you know the origin of this place?
How it came to be known as the Church of Vows?
Wait, I don't know.
What's that?
Well, that is a shame.
The shattering has caused us, all of us, to lose sight of something very dear.
It is here, at the Church of Vows, that the great houses of the earth tree and the moon were joined.
He gives spells and resets NPCs.
Oh, so he's a fucking nerd!
So he did all this magic bullshit.
And so, our church holds in view the monuments of both houses.
The earth tree of the capital and the academy of Rhea Lucaria.
Oh, was there something you needed?
You are free to show yourself around.
Yeah, my chest are used spells.
I would serve as your guide, only my legs aren't what they used to be.
If you find anything of use, you are free to take it with you.
Unless, perhaps, you are in search of instruction, in which case, I will share...
Wait, does the poke fight back?
Why are people dying?
Study sorcery.
Oh, we don't need that.
Those are for nerds.
I ain't no nerd.
You wish to know more of Lord Radigan.
Lord Radigan was a great champion.
Possessed of flow.
He came to these lands at the head of a great golden host.
When he met Lady Rinala in battle, he soon repented his territorial aggressions there.
And became husband to the Karian Queen.
Oh, good for him.
Good for him for finding a maiden.
The first Elden Lord was hounded from the lands between...
Oh, I know Godfrey!
That's the guy I killed!
I killed him!
Becoming Queen Marika's second husband and king consort.
Taking the title of second Elden Lord.
The mystery endures to this day as to why Lord Radigan would cast Lady Rinala aside.
And moreover, why a mere champion would be chosen for the seat of Elden Lord.
Oh, me?
Is there anything here for me?
You don't need absolution?
What does that mean?
Ah, fingers.
Whose fingers is it?
Gold sewing needle.
Oh.
I can be a tailor.
I can fix my clothes.
Dog ahead.
Is that it?
Praise the dog.
Alright, let's see.
Behold.
Rump.
Oh, where am I?
Wait, where am I anyway?
Oh, it's like a whole new area.
Here.
I guess I should go here and then follow this arrow.
I do want to kill some sheep.
For some extra loot.
Alright, get over...
Oh my god, you stupid bitch.
That's not efficient.
Like, where...
See, look at that.
That's right.
Fucking idiot.
You actually deserve to die.
There.
That's actual pure natural selection right there.
I'm trying to make sure no other sheep is bred to like roll...
To like bite its legs and start rolling.
They're the easiest to catch.
Alright.
I guess I have to go here?
Yeah.
Look, I need those bones for arrows, guys.
I need a craft.
Uh...
And I guess I'll just keep going forward.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure to eventually kill all the rolling sheep.
So I can save their species.
Get over here.
I need your bones!
Bones!
Nice.
Thank you for your bones.
Uh...
I guess I'll just go forward until something shows up.
And...
Wait, is that an item?
Oh, nice.
Yay!
Item!
Freestyle!
Night required ahead?
Oh, here?
Okay.
Yeah, I can...
I can...
I can wait for a night here.
Alright.
Uh...
Wait, is it night time yet?
This looks like night.
Oh, it is night!
Yay!
Oh, that's so pretty!
That's the Elden tree.
Oh, it was night?
Oh!
Couldn't tell.
Oh, wait, no.
I couldn't tell.
It's so bright for night time.
I assume...
Oh, Capo!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I assume it's here, right?
This is where I found the...
Yeah, this is where I found it.
Wait, night...
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
I was like, but night, Calvary.
Like, I look up and then there was a fucking name tag.
I was like, where did that...
Where is that?
Where is this guy?
Holy fuck!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Wait.
No, I can't summon.
I can't summon.
Oh, my God.
Thank God he missed.
Yes!
He missed again.
Haha, loser.
Oh!
You're not loser.
I'm sorry!
Oh, thank God.
The wall.
Okay.
God, get closer!
Get closer!
I'm not pussy magic user, so I need you to get closer!
Okay.
What?
That should not have hit.
That should not have hit right there.
Oh, my God.
Thank God I didn't hit, too.
Thank God he's just as bad.
Because it's nighttime, he can't see, too.
Oh, no.
All right.
No!
I didn't know you're batting yet!
All right.
Nice.
He missed again.
He keeps missing.
Ha, loser.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, my God.
Please.
What?
Are you serious?
He jumped!
He cheated!
Jumped!
Okay.
Alright.
Is it nighttime now?
Oh, shit.
Wait, no, it's not.
It's morning.
Alright, let me grab my stuff and then I'll go back to night.
I got too comfortable with influencer build.
I... I got... Holy... And the people are still trying to find my messages.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, my healing flash fucking sucks right now.
When laziness has failed me.
No!
Who's gonna enable me now?
Okay.
Oh, I don't have any secret tears.
It sucks.
It will do night.
Iggy, welcome to the mail farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright.
Here I go.
Okay, where is that guy again?
Oh, I have to find churches.
Oh, that's what increases the healing power.
So he should be here.
Okay, that means that... No, I have to explore more.
Oh, that's where he is.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm back.
Bitch, that's fucking right.
Damn it.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Nice.
No, not nice.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Why did I have it on my dagger?
Okay.
God damn it.
Oh, my rage.
No.
Nice.
No, not nice.
I can't forget he died.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Slowly backing out.
Alright, I need to figure out his pattern more.
And like, not... Oh, not get baited.
Come on, get back here.
Wait, what?
Wait, I'm right here.
No, I'm going to get back here.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That was a bait.
He's always trying to bait me.
Where are you going?
Hello?
I'm right here.
Like, what are you trying to do?
I'm so confused.
This movement is so confusing.
Hello?
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'll just stand here until you come back.
You'll eventually come back, right?
Damn it.
Oh, God!
I keep forgetting that attack!
When he does that, he does like a little charge thing.
God damn it.
No!
No, no, no, no!
Oh, my God.
I'm...
Come on.
Closer.
That's right.
What?
Fuck this.
Oh!
Never mind.
I won't try that again.
I'm sorry.
I'm...
Maybe if I take high ground?
It'd be easier.
God.
He just goes in.
He just does like a fucking...
Drive-by and then leaves.
Which is so annoying!
God, I hate it when he does that stupid drive-by.
All right, his horse is almost down.
Jesus fucking...
Get that horse out of here.
Get that fucking horse up.
That's right.
No more horse for you.
That's fucking right.
Whoa!
That's right.
You're nothing without your horse.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh my god, he just...
He
just...
He can just do that?
He can just like bring his horse back to life?
That's not fair.
That's not fucking fair!
What do you mean he can just fucking bring a second horse?
That's illegal!
Oh my god, appraise, please!
I've been waiting 20 years for my message, appraise!
Don't you...
Please!
I just need one!
One appraise, that's all I want!
Message appraise, please!
Oh god, just one!
Can't play right now, sorry.
Please!
My build can't work for...
I'm missing the one thing my build needs!
No!
Please, just one!
I beg of you, I just need one appraise!
Please!
Oh god.
Woo!
I have to play so safe right now!
I am...
Please!
Oh!
I just...
Want a breeze!
Buddy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
You're nothing without your horse.
All right, bad.
It's not... Brian, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's a good thing I always carry two horses.
My streamer failed!
The one thing I needed for my streamer failed is if someone actually appraised me.
Oh god, oh god, please let me at least grab my souls before you fuck me up.
Okay, wait, maybe...
Maybe I can sneak one in.
Oh, I can't, I can't... HE HAS MAGIC NOW?
WHERE DID HE HAVE MAGIC?
wait this is not him, this is not him.
I'll beat him up.
This is his brother.
I'll beat up his brother.
Oh shit, okay.
I'll beat up his little brother.
That's practice.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
That's fucking right.
I met your older brother, bitch.
Get out of here!
I'm sorry!
I'm not sorry!
Alright.
Okay.
Almost.
That was a little scary.
That was a little scary there.
Alright.
Now we go back.
Where the fuck is the... It's the grace.
Oh, it's right here.
I lost track of where the grace is.
I got a little cocky there.
Alright.
Now we rest for night time.
Round three.
Alright.
Okay.
To make this easy, I'll put it here.
First up.
Wait.
Is there, like, a praise in... Is there a praise in here?
Okay.
First up.
Actions.
No situation.
First up.
Appraisal.
Yes!
Where is it in?
Is it in concept?
Clap.
Please.
First up.
Help me.
Okay.
Let's sit here.
First up.
Help me.
Alright.
There we go.
That works.
Here we go.
Alright.
I'm ready.
This time.
Round three.
That's right.
Come on.
Yeah.
Sticky, right?
Oh!
Yeah!
First hit.
What?
Oh!
That doesn't... Oh!
That's... I thought that would give me, like, invincibility frames there.
Eye frames.
It doesn't.
Oh!
That's right.
Get over here.
Oh!
Fuck!
Never mind.
Don't get over here.
Okay.
Oh!
I keep forgetting that does, too.
That's what fucks with me the most.
Oh!
Jesus!
Have to drink one more.
And then he runs off.
He's like, give me a sec, guys.
I need... My horse needs to pee.
My horse... My horse needs a little bit of rest.
Okay.
At least... Oh!
What?
That still hits me?
Wait.
When he does... When he summons his horse, does it hurt me?
I'm curious.
Yes?
Okay.
That's good to know.
Actually, I really need to know that.
Okay.
Nice.
That misses.
Alright.
I have one more slash.
Woo!
Okay.
Nice.
That just missed me.
You serious?
Oh my...
God!
My sword just needs to be like one centimeter longer!
Here we go.
Come on.
No!
Literally one hit.
Woo!
Yeah!
I don't need no appraisal!
That's looking right!
Pure skill!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
We did it.
I'll need help, guys.
I told you.
I only did... I only use appraisal just for fun.
I could do it without you.
I did it.
Yeah.
Let's go back.
I need... I need my healers.
I need my flash.
I'm a strong independent streamer!
Alright.
Now just... I guess I'll go straight.
More exploring.
Are there any churches near me?
Chat?
Oh, you see those birds?
Wait.
Actually, we need to get rid of these guys first.
I should have enough to upgrade, too.
I should have enough.
Alright.
Oh, I have enough?
Oh, I do!
Alright, guys.
What do we have to focus on?
Was it Dexterity?
Or was it Arcane?
It was Arcane, right?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the... Wow, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for the message of praise.
I really appreciate that.
Dexterity.
Okay.
Alright.
Wow, guys.
See?
Oh, it must have been lag, right?
Like, you just got to that part where I...
Where I fought the night guy.
Alright.
I'm gonna kill this family of birds.
There can only be one bird here.
That's right.
Tell your kids what I did!
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I killed your only child.
Never mind.
That's right.
Tell the other eagles!
I'll kill all your children.
It was the stream delay, right, guys?
I hate how the younger brother is a magic user.
That's right.
Your older brother didn't need magic.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You'll never beat him.
Your older brother never needed magic to kick my ass.
Alright.
Nice.
And I'll kill you.
Because I need your bones for arrows.
I don't know where am I.
Hmm.
I guess I'll head straight?
Yeah, I'll head straight.
See where that takes me.
Let me kill these guys for fun.
Oh, what?
You're gonna blow your fucking horn?
Pussy?
That's right.
No horn blowing for you!
Oh my god.
Who's using that?
Is that him?
Is that you?
Oh, it was you!
Jeez, it took so long for you to charge.
Okay.
Let me get rid of all the little guys first.
Oh!
I sent the little guys!
I'll kick you on later!
Oh, wait.
That guy's pretty big.
Wait.
No.
All right.
You know what to do.
Take care of this guy.
I sent this guy!
I need to get rid of the small guy first.
Okay.
Jellyfish, please.
Jellyfish.
Yes!
Aggro him!
Do your thing!
And I'll do my thing, too.
Watch.
Ha-ha!
Shit, I've got distracted, buddy!
That's fucking right!
Oh, shit.
All right.
Do your thing, Jellyfish.
Do your thing.
Aggro him, buddy.
Come on, buddy!
Aggro him!
You got this!
Yeah!
Ha-ha!
You got distracted again!
That's right!
Get out of here!
Give me your shit.
That's fucking right!
Get backshot!
Had lots of practice earlier!
Uh...
Let's trade, then.
That's right!
I had a lot of practice on those hunters.
In Halo.
I'm really good at it now.
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
What do you mean?
I had so much practice yesterday, guys!
All I did was...
Was doing my deadly backshots.
Left and right.
All right.
Get out of here.
Ooh!
Sniper ahead?
Wait, where?
Here?
Might be here.
Where would the sniper be?
AHH!
Guys, it was over there.
Guys.
I think I know where the sniper is, guys.
I think...
I think I found the sniper, Chad.
I...
I think I found him.
All right.
How do we get to the sniper?
Oh, hey.
Free stuff.
How do we get there?
Oh, it's from here.
Oh, there's multiple.
Oh, okay.
It's guarded.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm...
Uh...
I'm broken by.
Thank you, this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, how do I...
How do I get to there safely?
It's like here?
Oh, here.
Oh, wait.
What?
How do I hit that?
How the fuck do I hit that?
It's like attached to the wall.
Wait, this is more important.
It's loot.
God damn it.
Okay, I can...
I don't have arrows still.
Wait, do I?
Wait, I might be able to craft arrows now.
Oh, I can.
Nice.
All right.
I just have...
I just had enough arrows.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna go up here.
I'm gonna go up here.
And then...
No!
Fine, I didn't want to be up here anyway.
Did I craft the wrong arrows?
Wait, what?
Wait.
No.
There's no way.
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna be like, there's no way I...
I crafted the wrong arrow.
I'll be so sad.
All right, how do I use this again?
Okay, I'm trying to remember how to use my arrows.
Okay, nice.
And then...
There we go.
Yeah!
What did I get?
What the fuck did I get?
What was that?
What the fuck?
Oh, I got...
Oh, I got an Estes!
Oh!
Oh, so that was a waste of my arrows.
What the fuck?
It was just healing.
Oh my god, that was a waste.
Okay.
I need to know, like, distinguish between this...
The two fucking...
Oh, sorry.
The three bugs.
Oh god.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I can't use it.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, what?
No, I'm trapped!
I'm trapped!
Oh!
There was a wall!
Oh, shit.
I didn't dodge that.
Oh.
Oh!
I don't know your pattern, sir!
I cheated to kill you, your first brother!
I didn't bother to learn!
Oh, no!
No!
Okay.
I know how to...
Wait.
I guess the...
Steak would be closer, right?
It should be.
Technically.
I have the jellyfish help me!
Oh god.
Not again.
Okay.
Okay, now I have the jellyfish again.
Dad, thank you.
Welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Okay.
Oh.
Alright, there we go.
Where is it?
Here we go.
Okay, I'm just gonna leave.
I don't think it's important in any way to fight him.
Alright, I'll just go here.
The big scary temple.
Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the big scary temple.
I don't think he was that important in any way.
Alright, up I go!
Big scary temple time!
Oh, what's this?
Oh, nice.
Got some grease.
There's another grease here.
That's good.
We actually needed that.
Grace restored.
Alright, El Faco.
Hello?
Is anybody here?
Grand life of Dectus?
Hello?
Anyone alive?
Is anyone alive?
Anyone?
There's an elevator?
Where's that elevator be?
Oh, wait.
There's a person here.
Hey there, buddy.
Where's what?
Oh, I don't have to write.
Oh, I need a key item.
Oh!
I'm not worthy enough.
I see.
I'm not good enough for her.
Alright, so...
Since I can't go there yet...
Grand line...
I mean...
What's over here?
Wait, why is that red?
What is over here?
There's something red over there.
Ooh.
Try target lock?
What is that?
Well, it's just some bats.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
There's nothing to be afraid of down here.
Just some little bats.
Yeah, see?
Try this guy.
Just some little bats.
I think he's so cool.
Get over here.
Oh my god, please.
Please, you're...
No!
Do not roll out!
That's right.
Oh, nice.
I needed that, too.
I actually need that for a sword upgrade.
Okay.
Oh my god, these guys died to bats?
Oh my god.
How bad are you?
There's not that many bats.
Come on.
How could you die to these little guys?
Look at them.
They're so weak.
How could you guys die to that?
Oh no, they didn't.
What the?
Do a flip.
Where are they trying to go?
And then likely light.
Oh!
Hmm.
I don't know about that.
I don't know.
I want to try.
Guys, I don't think they died to bats.
They may or may not have died to something known as gravity.
That's gonna be me.
Oh my god.
That's gonna be me!
I can feel it!
Guys, it can still be bats, guys.
Okay, maybe I'll look at this guy and see.
Okay, what the fuck did this guy do?
Oh.
Oh, he missed.
Okay.
I don't know.
I feel like... I feel like it might not be worse than it.
Chat, I don't know.
Oh, but it goes through the black hole.
There was just a lot of bats down there, Doki.
I don't know.
Feels like...
Feels a little dangerous.
Okay, it's worth it.
Okay, what do I get out of it?
Tell me.
What do I get out of it if I try to go down to the bat hole?
You're different?
Alright, I have 6,000... Okay.
When I get rid of, like, my runes, I'll try.
I'll try it.
I'll try it when I get out of my... When I upgrade my runes.
Let's see.
Alright, go then.
I guess I'll go this way.
There's nowhere else to go.
Uh, Zapko!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
If you learn to save quick...
Save quick fast enough, you never have to worry about gravity!
Guys, I'm really struggling right now to walk.
I don't think I can save quick fast enough.
What's that?
What's that sound?
Oh, hey, is that coming towards me?
Oh!
It
was like, fuck you!
Damn!
Oh, shit!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no!
Okay.
So, that was madness.
That was...
You know, like, you're, you know, things like how you're not supposed to look at...
You're not supposed to look at the, at the sun during a solar eclipse.
Oops.
I didn't know... that's me right there.
I'm the guy that looked... I'm... I'm the people that looked up directly into the... into the solar eclipse.
Okay.
Uh... Can I even go up here?
Or like, am I fucked?
Just close your eyes!
How the fuck do I...?
Oh, wait, I just stay out of sight?
It's like here, right?
Oh, I think he got crazy.
Let's kill this big rat first.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
Okay, I'll go this way.
Alright, and then... Where do I go from here?
Oh, wait, no.
I'm still getting... Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Okay, right here.
That's the spot.
Yeah, just wait behind this tree.
I don't think he saw me.
Okay, the rat saw me.
The rat... Guys, the rat... What?!
What?!
No way!
No!
Are you fucking dead to a rat?!
No way!
Oh... Stupid fucking ass!
Oh my god!
Okay, we gotta get my souls back.
Great.
The rat madness got me, guys.
Still no precious items.
Still no lover.
It feels bad, man.
That's rough, buddy.
Okay.
Okay, now I know what to do.
Stupid rat that I use.
Quick attack.
Okay.
Alright, I can grab my item bath.
I go this way.
And then... Go this way.
And then... This is not in view, right?
Yeah, right here.
Oh, then ring requires.
Require it ahead.
And then seek.
Wait, I don't have the elder ring.
Get right on.
Zeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, where do I get the elder ring?
Just got here.
Okay.
Okay, now I should be safe.
Thank god.
I'm safe now.
What's this?
First off, left?
I mean this guy?
What?
Oh, can I kill the guy that does the madness stuff?
Likely dark lord.
Can't be that bad, right?
Oh!
Okay, I can't do anything yet.
I have to wait.
Give me a sec.
I gotta wait.
Alright.
I can't do!
Oh my god, he's guarded by all these rats!
Holy shit, that's a big-ass rat!
It's not fair!
He has so many rats!
It's all rats!
Oh my god, it's just all rats!
Oh, thank you.
Missed such a phrase.
Thank you.
I can't.
I really appreciate it.
Oh man.
Thank you guys.
I know.
It was a really good message.
It was...
It was a really, really good message.
How many rats?
Oh my god.
It was just rats.
It was only rats.
Okay, I figured it out though.
I figured it out.
I know what to do this time.
And we go this way.
And then we go this way.
And then...
We go here.
We hide here in this corner.
And we should be okay.
And then...
And then we go this way.
I'm gonna hug the wall so it can't get me.
And then...
And then we got this.
We gotta let this cool down.
Before I go up there again.
Wait, materials?
What materials is this?
Yellow ember.
Okay, I gotta get my shit back though.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
Please, I'm trying...
Oh, no!
Oh my god.
I'm trying to like...
It won't let me down.
But it kept trying to...
It kept like...
Jumping instead.
Oh my god.
I was trying to get off my horse.
But I was also trying to dodge the rats at the same time.
So then my horse, instead of getting off...
It starts jumping around.
Because I've been trying to get away from the rats.
I was locked in the room.
Filled with rats.
What do I do?
I can't believe it.
Most of my deaths this run...
Is just from the rats alone.
It's not a boss fight.
It's literally just the rats.
The fucking rats.
Okay.
I'll cool down.
A rat fight.
Oh shit.
My toe is peeking out of that wall.
Alright.
Yo, yo.
We just wait.
Alright.
Oh my god.
They're actually guarding my...
Oh!
Oh my god.
The stupid rats!
No!
It's fine.
Oh my god.
It's not fine.
He's such a big rat.
He's such a big boy.
Alright.
There we go.
It's okay.
We're okay.
Madness ahead.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Whoa, really?
Wow.
Alright.
Who is this fucker?
That's ruining my day.
And inviting all these goddamn rats.
Who is it?
Who are you?
Oh, I see you.
It was you?
Oh, oh, I got hit by madness.
Okay, I'm just climbing a ladder.
I climbed a ladder and got hit.
Alright, okay.
No, no, that's fair.
That's fair.
Let me, let me stay down here.
Let me just open your chest.
That's fine.
I'll just, I'll just stay down here.
All right, I can wait.
Okay.
Yeah.
There we go.
And then I just start swinging.
Oh my God.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
How many are you?
How are you still praying?
Okay, there we go.
They're all dead.
Thank God.
No madness ahead.
We did it.
We cure the world of madness.
Don't need therapy anymore, guys.
We did it.
No more therapy.
We fucking did it, guys.
Flush away those meds.
But like, in-game.
In-game, guys.
In-game.
I cured Elden Ring mental illness.
That's different.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, if I die to fucking dogs, I swear to God.
Depression eliminated.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh.
That guy looks like a big butt guy.
Looks like a big boy.
Alright, let me...
Drink some of his.
You think I can take him?
I think I can take him.
That's right.
I cured schizophrenia.
And insanity.
And psychopaths.
Psychopathy?
How did this guy die?
I cured them all.
You're welcome.
Now you don't have to take meds anymore.
Oh, this guy looks big.
Wait, what if I can...
Oh, I know what to do.
Get over here.
Matt.
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait.
Actually, I think I can actually...
Oh!
Oh, wait!
Don't think I can take him.
Oh my God.
Wait, I actually don't think I can take him.
Wait, I don't think I can take him, guys.
And he knows...
Who doesn't do magic?
Holy fu...
WHY DOES EVERYONE IN THIS WORLD KNOW MAGIC?!
Okay, guys, I don't think I can take him.
I don't think I can take him, guys.
I'm just gonna leave.
I know he's too thick for this.
There's no way he can get in here.
Okay, man, he light my way.
Ooh, what's this?
You must have a puzzle.
I can't solve puzzles?!
Is hitting things solving a puzzle?
Fiddle time!
Where the fuck is the...?
Oh, it's outside.
But he's outside.
Oh, no.
He's outside, though.
He's just waiting for me.
Where could this puzzle be?
Down here?
Oh, hey.
Grab this item.
I think there's anything here.
No dead end ahead?
What is a dead end?
There's nothing here.
Oh!
At least I got some mushrooms.
I don't think I have it.
Canyon emote?
Okay, I definitely don't have it.
I know that for sure.
Alright, guess we don't do a riddle.
No riddles for me.
How did people die here?
Okay, we're not doing that.
There's a lot of deaths here.
Wait.
This one might be easy.
But where does he go after that?
Okay.
I did it!
Yay!
I mean, I assume it's here.
Yeah.
Wait, how did he fuck it up?
Where the fuck was he going?
What the fuck?
That was so easy!
How did they fuck that up?
Seek precious item and then try self?
Oh!
Is there a precious item here?
I don't see anything.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I don't have magic.
God damn it.
Okay, there...
Okay, this is...
Okay.
There might be a grace nearby.
Maybe I'll find a grace.
Okay, guys.
Is there a grace anywhere?
I might need to refill some magic.
And some...
And some heals.
No, I don't think it'll be fine.
Guys!
Guys, he's glowing!
I don't...
I don't think it'll be fine.
He's fucking glowing!
It's behind him?!
Okay.
Alright.
I have a horse.
Maybe I can run past him.
Alright.
Okay, it's behind him.
That's fine.
That makes it easier then.
I can just grab my stuff back then from him.
It's just friendship, Aura.
Doki.
It just means he's a really good friend.
Wait, where is behind?
Guys, he's slowly walking towards me.
A god damn mosquito got me!
Please!
Open faster!
For the love of god!
It's not that heavy!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Thank god!
Please!
Sit down!
Oh!
Thank god!
I sat down!
It's fine.
I...
I sat down.
It's okay.
Alright.
We're fine.
Okay.
I don't think he knows.
What?!
He doesn't?!
I go back downstairs.
I...
Okay.
I do it this time.
Alright.
But I also wanna make sure...
Okay.
I did...
There we go.
We're fine.
We're so healthy now.
Oh my god.
He's TPing.
That should be illegal.
Oh my god!
What?!
He's faster?!
Oh!
And he dodged it?!
Oh oh oh oh.
Oh oh oh oh oh oh.
Yeah.
He can't TP forever.
Okay.
Maybe you can.
Oh you are definitely faster!
Oh you are so much faster than me!
Oh.
What?!
Oh my...
Guys.
I'm really worried about what this, the symbol means at the bottom.
I'm so worried.
Sorry, I don't know what it means, and I'm trying to make sure I don't get hit from whatever it is.
I hate you.
It looks so omnibus.
Okay, now I know.
I hate you.
Oh!
Okay, I'm trying to make sure he doesn't get close to getting that bar full up, because I don't want to know what it does.
I really don't... I really don't want to know what it does, guys.
I don't feel confident.
Nice.
What the...
No!
No, no, no, no!
That almost killed me.
Oh, that almost killed me.
Oh!
Yes!
Oh, thank God!
I don't...
I just didn't want to know...
I really didn't want to know what it does.
It seems so dangerous!
Oh, thank God!
He's dead!
Okay.
And this is a dungeon, right?
He respawned?!
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, so there...
That was like...
No point.
That...
That was actually no point in me doing that.
He was just gonna respy.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
For gear?
What kind of gear does he give?
Wait, does he regenerate?
Okay, so I had to double kill him.
Then what the fuck was the point?!
If he could just come back to life like that.
Time for pickle.
Oh, that has to be a guy.
Yeah, I knew it.
That's fucking right.
Get distracted!
Because you have to readjust your head!
Oh.
I can't go through that.
Oh, I forgot again.
Oh!
That's fine.
Wait.
I'm trying to...
Wait!
I'm trying to kill this one guy!
Alright.
Okay, there were so many enemies there.
Oh.
Sage, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is that an archer?
Oh my god, it is an archer.
Oh, it is.
No, I'm trying to read my message!
Didn't expect high...
Okay.
High ground.
What do you mean, high ground?
I'M TRIED TO READ!
Didn't expect high road.
Okay.
I got this.
Okay, I can kill him.
Alright, I'm gonna get him out first.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
There!
It was against the wall!
It's not fair!
How can I kill it in his... against the fucking...
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please, I'm trying to get above.
Wait, how do I get above it?
Oh my god.
Okay, clear it up.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my god, there you are.
It must be you.
It's you, isn't it?
It's you!
Okay, okay, now he's dead.
Thank God.
Alright.
Okay, I need to figure out where the necromancer is.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
There you- Oh no!
Message of praise!
Message of praise, please!
Okay.
Oh my god, I hate them.
I hate all of them.
They're so annoying.
No hidden path ahead.
Attacking ahead.
Wait, I don't think you have- Oh ho ho!
I know you don't have a necromancer.
That's right!
No one will help you now.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, who's gonna help me?
Who's- No!
Oh!
Yes!
Ah!
Oh!
Somebody help me!
Wait!
Where's the necromancer?
Okay.
Wait, but like, is this a good hole or a bad hole?
Guys.
I can't tell if it's a good hole or a bad hole.
Hit the wall.
Hit the wall?
Which one?
This one?
Oh!
Ooh!
Magic!
Oh shit.
Okay, wait.
I have what- I have enough to level up.
I'm going back down.
Okay, guys.
I know how to get back here.
I'm going to go level up real fast.
I don't want to lose my shit.
I- I don't want to- Guys.
I don't want to lose my XP.
All right.
Dungeon will reset.
It's okay.
I can just run past all of them.
Guys.
I don't trust the process.
That's the thing.
I- I know me.
I know myself.
I 100% do not trust the process.
All right.
Level up.
Dexterity.
Okay, here we go.
All right, now- Okay, now I know what to do.
We can just get past all of these, actually.
And you know what?
I'm going to run past all of them.
I don't think it really matters.
It's like here.
And then...
Okay.
Here we go.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha!
Here we go.
And then...
Okay, and then we kill him.
Oh shit!
I forgot about him!
No!
Ha ha ha!
I got comboed!
Ah!
Holy shit!
I got comboed so- Oh my god!
I was like, ha ha!
I remember all of this!
But do you, Toki?
Do you really remember all of this?
Guys, I didn't remember all of it.
Jokes on me.
I didn't.
She did not.
Okay, now!
Okay.
Oh god.
Please, please seek me up.
Please seek me up.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
Get my shit back real fast.
Okay, that's not me.
That's actually on me.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That's on me!
I deserved it!
Okay.
Alright.
Now we just hit the wall.
Dang!
What a shot!
Alright.
Let's see what this brings me.
Who are you?
Oh, I can't...
I can't use...
He's so fast!
Wait, he's so fast!
I don't like that!
Oh my god!
Why are you so fast?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh no.
Five.
Oh, it's not five.
It's not five.
Woo!
Nice.
Okay.
Sneer recharge.
Oh!
Stop lying!
It's cheating!
Nice.
Okay.
No!
He predicted me!
You know what?
He knew what I wanted to do!
He was like...
Get predicted!
He knew!
He's so smart!
No!
He predicted!
He...
He predicted me!
I panicked!
He faded me!
I started panicking!
I was so close too!
He read me like a book!
He threw fire at me and then I kept... stop, drop, and roll!
I was like, if I stop, drop, and roll, I'll live!
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
Alright.
Ow.
That's it.
I'm leaving.
I'm...
Holy shit.
Please let me leave.
Oh, please.
Please just let me leave.
Oh, there's so many arrows.
Please.
Oh.
That's fine.
I'm going in with one, two less... two less grenade... two less heals, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Okay.
I don't need it.
I don't... I don't need it, guys.
I definitely don't need it.
Let me grab this first, before you beat me up.
Woo!
Jesus Christ.
It's so fast.
I hate it.
Okay.
Focus, Doki.
Focus.
Whoa!
No!
I said focus, not the other way around!
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh.
I have to dodge in.
Just in time.
Oh, no!
Not in time!
I lied!
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
Sometimes I can't see, like, where he's...
where he's trying to move, because he's so... he, like, blends in.
He actually blends in sometimes, and it's so annoying.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, no.
Please.
I won't be greedy.
Yes!
I got greedy!
It worked!
Oh, thank God!
Thank God for being greedy!
Thank fucking God!
Sage regret.
That's fucking right.
A weak foe.
Return me to the entrance!
Am I done with this dungeon?
Or, like, is there more?
There's still more?
Oh, that wasn't a main boss?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I gotta find the ending for this.
Oh, that was a secret boss.
Okay.
Oh, I assume that's where the boss is.
I just need to figure out how to get out of here.
Alright.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Goodbye.
Okay, I didn't want...
Oh!
God, hello!
Hello.
Slatter.
God?
Oh.
I mean, they seem nice.
Oh my God!
Oh!
None of you are nice, though!
Not you!
Oh, but this guy is a regular skeleton, so I don't have to worry about it.
Okay.
Okay, the only issue is that this guy is a necromancer skeleton, so...
Uh...
I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
I'm just gonna leave.
Pathetic sword ahead?
Aww...
Oh!
Oh,
I don't...
Oh!
Okay!
Okay.
Okay, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Yeah.
Bye.
Oh, there's two of you.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Yeah, kill your kids.
That's right.
You're only killing your children.
Bye.
It's okay.
My ass cushioned it all.
Where do I go?
Like, do I go back down here?
What the fuck do I do?
Is that where I have to go?
There's a good hole?
When are holes good?
Oh, there's a hole by the secret boss.
Every hole is good, Doki.
What do you mean?
Shit.
I swear!
Oh my god!
Fuck you!
Actual fuck you!
Oh my god.
Woo!
That good hole.
I remember now.
Good hole time.
Okay.
I'm on the other side.
Too much.
All right.
Okay.
I... Okay.
That's... This is... Okay.
Thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
Like, why can't I fucking... Oh!
There's so many things here.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Super regenerating skeleton.
Skeleton.
Spooky scary skeleton.
Ba ba dum ba dum bum.
Ba dum ba dum bum.
Alright, nice.
Alright, you go back.
Alright.
Back into the scary the scary corridor again.
This time I'll win.
Yeah I win.
Just a flesh wound, guys.
I'll still win.
I'm okay.
Don't worry, it's just a flesh wound.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
Alright, let me save...
Let me get some heals real quick.
Am I close enough to level up?
No.
Oh, I could kill two skellies.
If I kill two skellies, I should be good.
I'll just farm this guy.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
I need your XP!
That's right!
Oh, never mind.
It's more than two skellies, guys.
It's definitely a lot more.
Ooh, is it worth it?
To go down now.
I could level up one more.
Oh yeah, I have runes!
You're right!
I almost forgot about that.
I have runes.
Alright, let me get the runes real quick.
Um... Oh, no.
Equipment.
Wait, no.
Sorry.
It's like third time's the charm.
200.
I should use this one then.
That should be enough.
Level up.
Never mind.
One more.
one more for the road.
Boop!
Alright.
Level up.
Dexterity, vigor, or arcane?
Chat.
Vigor?
Dexterity?
Some arcane?
Okay.
I'll do arcane.
Does the arcane help move my bleed damage now?
I don't know if I'll hit the bleed, though.
Yeah?
Yes?
No?
Yeah?
It'll fill faster?
Okay.
Alright, I'll do arcane then.
Okay, and then... Do I have enough for flask?
I don't know.
No, how about the amount?
No.
Unlucky.
Oh, is there something I could equip?
Oh!
Ooh!
I can get rid of this for vitality.
Alright, nice.
Wait, how did I...
How did I get, like, crazy already?
What the fuck?
Why is there, like, that thing at the bottom?
Oh!
Just because I equipped it?
Try summoning?
Wait, how bad is this?
Wait...
How...
How bad is it that it requires me?
Praise...
Praise the bird.
Praise the bird!
Alright...
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Okay, I was definitely not ready.
To be fair, he like just... he peed in front of me!
It was like teleport behind you.
Oh my god, and he did it again!
He did it again!
No!
Wait, my junkfish is dead already?
How?
He just... I need to...
Okay, before... Okay, I'm gonna try and get this skeleton out of the way.
But do they come... Do these skeletons keep spawning?
I need to know.
Before... No?
Okay.
I... I'm... I'm so sad.
I'm... I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
Like... Oh, he's so weak!
Wait, he's so weak!
Wait a minute!
He's so weak!
Why was I so afraid?
I know you're weak.
I'm not...
What?
Okay.
Okay, I got a little too cocky.
I... Oh my god.
I got too cocky.
I got... I don't need a dodge.
You're so weak.
This is the average.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
I know now.
I know.
I understand.
It's okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay, I just need to grab this.
I know it's not a lot, but it's still me.
I fucking hate you!
AHHHH!
Are you serious?
It's teammates!
He brought his whole squad!
Okay, okay, wait, I get it now.
Okay, I'm gonna clear the skellies first.
I... I'm gonna... I'm gonna clear the skellies.
He brought... Bro, he brought the homies!
To the LAN party!
That's not fair!
I said 1v1!
1v1!
Fox only!
No items!
Final destination!
And then he brought, like, three other people to join him.
Like, I don't know, I think that's cheating.
That may or may not be against the rules.
Where's the ref when you need him?
I swear!
I... Are you serious?
Okay!
Okay, buddy!
That's... Okay.
Like, I don't know about you guys, but I think I need the ref here right now.
I... I...
Where the fuck is that ref?
Holy shit!
He primed the ref!
The ref is also a skeleton!
Where the fuck was the casters?
Why did the casters not
come...
So weak!
He was the ref!
Please, jellyfish, please!
Aggro one of them!
Oh my god, please!
I... One of them!
That's all I ask!
One of them!
Aggro one of them!
Just!
Not him!
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
Fine!
That's not fine!
I don't feel fine anymore!
You're such a BITCH!
BITCH!
I can't believe...
Does he really need all of those abilities?
He brought, like, four teammates!
And then he has to have a stun!
And a grab!
And, like, 800 attack!
Does he really need all of that?
Like, he's so weak, by the way!
He's so weak!
Like, let's see...
Oh!
I hate you!
I hope...
I hope you never find love!
I swear to god...
I swear...
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
I'm a glass cannon Bill...
Tiff!
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Okay...
Okay.
I-I-I got this.
Yeah!
This approach.
I hope you die alone...
For the rest of your life!
Alright.
The power of friendship goes off.
Bro, okay, I'm fucking rid of him.
That's it.
Oh my god.
Oh my... Okay.
Guys, please.
Can someone message or praise one thing?
One time.
I just need one message of praise.
That's all I need.
Please.
Just one message of praise.
Just... Okay.
Are you serious?
Okay.
That's good.
Please.
Just one message of praise.
That's all I need.
Okay.
Never mind.
That's fine.
Oh, thank you.
I... thanks.
You guys did it.
You did it.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys.
It's fine.
We did it.
Is that what you wanted, Doki?
You said one.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to be, like, super careful right now.
Cause... this guy has fucked me up.
I hate you.
I HATE YOU!
AHHHHH!
He just... AHHHHH!
My TP!
My T... I roll back ETPs forward!
I...
Oh my god.
I should have rolled forward!
Why did I roll forward?
Why did I roll backwards?
Oh my god.
Doesn't matter.
I just wanna kill him.
Okay, nice.
NOOOOO!
He killed my plan!
He saw right through me!
Fuck me and my bros.
Feeding up this fucking VTuber.
Okay.
Alright, slow and steady.
Slow and steady, Doki.
Clearly not...
Too slow!
Too slow, Doki!
I hate you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Okay.
That's good.
I hate you.
I hate you!
AHHHHH!
NO!
No, NO!
NOOO!
OH, TANK GOD!
One fear and it's that fucking move...
That move has killed me too many times.
Yes!
Oh, thank you!
Oh, thank god!
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it!
Give me this box!
Give me your fucking treasures!
Oh, therefore seek- was it- therefore seek- hole!
Oh, oh, oh!
That...
Where did I kill him?
I killed you right here!
Oh wait, no, you died here.
Message.
First off...
Corpse... that's right.
Get out of here!
Try and bring a fucking gang to a 1v1!
Get out!
How dare you!
I said 1v1!
Alright.
I don't know, this guy- I don't wanna fight him.
He already fucked me up.
He can have this area.
Wait, actually.
You see, I just think I- wait, I might be- I might have enough to level up, actually.
Wait.
Get off my horse, and then...
I might be able to level up my sword.
And stuff.
Alright.
Greetings.
Hello!
Oh, yes!
Okay.
And then...
Well, I took you for no matter.
And say out your arms, then.
Alright, let's see.
Do I have enough?
I need...
Two more smithing stone.
How do I get that?
Two finger?
It was two fingers.
Oh, I'm missing one.
How do I get more?
What?
Look at me!
I'm blinged out!
Look how fucking sick I look!
What do you mean I haven't earned it yet?
I look so fucking sick!
It says I had to go forward here, but...
I feel like...
I don't have the item yet for it.
So I guess not?
And this here says I should go forward.
Woah.
Wait, talk the fingers?
Upstairs?
I have to go upstairs here?
I
had my doubts.
Look at you.
Only once before have I seen two great runes together.
Woah!
The fingers shudder with exuberance.
Whose fingers is that?
Fine work, brave tarnished.
The greater will is pleased.
You have earned the right to become...
Me?!
Me!
You think that's two fingers?
Because he has two fingers?
Two fingers?
To become Elden Lord.
And restore...
How do we know it's fingers and not toes?
The fingers expect...
As much from you as they do young Gideon.
Take this.
A token of farewell.
Yay!
Oh, a talisman pouch.
I would know if they were...
They could be really, really long toes.
You don't know that.
They're not...
Clearly they're not human toes.
Yeah, right?
But like...
Oh wait, maybe I can go down from here.
And then go down from here.
You know what?
I think I can do it.
Oh, I can equip more talisman now?
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
I think I can do it.
Remember all those like bats down there?
I think I can beat the bats.
Alright.
Watch this.
Wait, less people died here.
Guys, there were a lot of bats down there.
Guys, bats caught me.
Guys.
It was the bats.
I think it was caught.
Oh my God.
I...
I got sworn by all those bats, guys.
Holy shit.
It was crazy.
I did not expect to see it.
That many bats.
Oh my God.
I did not mean to do that.
I...
I got kicked off.
I got off my horse and it pushed me into the cliff.
My horse literally pushed me back down.
Okay.
Those...
Sorry.
Those gosh darn bats pushed me down into the bat hole.
No horse.
Alright.
We're not going that way.
We're not.
Alright.
We're gonna figure out how to get there.
We're gonna figure out a different parkour route.
Right here?
How the fuck did these guys die?
You sinking?
Oh.
You thought about it.
But it didn't work out, guys.
Well done.
Why?
Praise the jumping.
First off, well done.
Oh, here?
Wait, why?
Is there a parkour here?
And that's why people are like, good job?
Oh, I guess like they went from here to here.
Where?
Look for the church?
I see no church.
I assume it's here to here.
And everybody's like, good job you did it.
I see no church anywhere.
Is there a church yet?
Oh, I see it!
Is that a church?
Wow, rune art?
It's so?
Alright, let's try to get a church.
We might need to increase our flask.
Like, we definitely need to increase it.
Our shit is so fucking weak right now.
Oh, there's a grace here.
Wait.
I've been to that grace before.
I'm pretty sure.
Right?
No, I haven't.
Oh no, I haven't!
No, this is a new area.
Alright.
Yay!
Guys, I'm not going back with my souls.
I've given up.
Look, it was just a thousand.
I can get it back.
Is there like, a flask here then?
Since it's a church?
Oh!
Wait, there's another grace.
Oh wait, no.
I was in this grace.
It was in front of me this entire time.
There you go.
Sacred tear.
Ron's like, oh look!
I found it!
Wait, I was here.
Okay.
Yes, please.
Alright.
Guess we head down here.
Yeah.
This should take us downstairs now.
Oh, there's a person!
Something incredible?
This guy?
Why is he incredible?
What do you need?
I don't want any trouble.
Does he have a...
No, he's not that good.
Not really what I need right now.
I see.
Donkey.
A key.
Dog.
I like that.
Wait.
Is there...
Wait, what is it?
Concepts?
Is a dog a concept, guys?
Wait, wait.
Did that say frog?
Oh, it said rod.
I thought that said rat.
Wait.
Dog.
Dog's not an enemy!
Wait.
Actually...
Dog friend!
Bird.
Bird!
Seed ahead.
Therefore, try.
Campsite ahead.
Therefore, time for tranquility.
Merchant?
Friendly?
Fucking liars.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Why are they so strong?
Okay, I was not ready for that.
I didn't realize they were so strong.
It's like they were made out of rocks or some shit.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my God!
What is wrong with your skin, buddy?
It's like their skin is made out of rocks.
Could this be a merchant?
Merchant?
In the mines.
Yeah.
Wait, they're like mine people?
What the fuck?
Why don't I get like...
Why didn't I get like free rocks from them?
I deserve free rocks.
First they mine, then they craft.
Let's heal.
I'll fight him.
Oh, nevermind.
I wanted my friend to fight him for me.
But nevermind.
Um...
Okay, that's fine.
Oh!
That's not fine, that's not fine.
So I can do this again.
Okay.
Jesus.
All right.
That's fine.
I have heals.
Woo!
He blocked it!
That should be illegal.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Why aren't you bleeding?
Why are...
No!
I got greedy.
Ah!
I was like, he's one.
I'm one.
I'm faster.
I'll be easy.
Guess it wasn't easy.
It wasn't.
Oh!
Why am I always so greedy?
I can't help it!
How's late?
I'm faster.
I'm Tanya.
I have less clothes on.
I'm more aerodynamic.
This is a greedy talk about in the Bible.
Okay, now...
Oh, thank you guys.
Thank you.
I think I just...
I think you're that delayed.
Alright, he wins.
Hey, what's these?
Hey, what are these?
What are those though?
Wait, I...
I think I can take him though.
I think I can take him.
I have an idea.
He can jump?
Okay, but can he do it again?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh my god.
He can't jump forever.
I knew you can.
That's right.
That's okay.
I still have the hot ground.
I still have it.
I figured it out.
I'm going to start diving.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh shit.
That's...
Oh shit!
Please!
He's one hit!
Let me be free greedy!
Please!
Oh my god.
I don't trust myself.
Okay.
My high ground!
He has to come down.
And when he comes down, I go back up.
There we go.
When he comes down, I just have to go back up.
There we go!
I did it!
The power of high ground!
And all I got is 400 points!
Let's go!
You're at Bumbreed Island.
What is that?
That seems very dangerous.
I'm not gonna...
That seems like it'll explode.
It's very...
What's the word?
It feels very explodey.
Oh no.
I can tell that he respawns.
He looks very respawnable.
He really did look very respawnable.
So don't worry.
I know.
Alright.
Oh!
Yeah.
Loot.
Loot, loot.
Is that Grace?
It is.
Nice.
Yeah, it looked very, like, explodable.
It's like a pimple that's about to pop.
Okay.
There's a mine?
Oh, a smithing stone.
I need that.
Yeah, it's ready to go kablooey.
That be a river?
Do I climb up from the Grace?
Like...
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I didn't see the ladder.
Alright, ladder time.
Up I go.
Up ladder.
Ladder up.
Oh, I forgot I put my lantern...
Is my lantern on?
I don't think it is.
There you go.
Yeah, I forgot I had that.
What the fuck?
That's a tumor.
That's a tumor!
I'm cured cancer.
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
Cause we all know that there's only one tumor.
Alright.
Oh, I can get smithing stone here.
Right?
Okay, if I don't bother him, it should be fine.
I'm pretty sure, like, he doesn't care.
Yeah.
Okay, that's good.
Cause he's way too tanky.
I just won't bother him.
As long as they don't care, it's fine.
Beware of left.
That guy?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Liar ahead?
Beware of poison.
Wait, what?
Who has poison?
I don't think this is...
Oh.
Okay.
I deserve that.
I really do.
I...
I deserve that.
It was...
It was right there.
Oh my god!
How many...
Oh my god, I...
I'm already poisoned.
I don't know what...
Are you gonna give me a bestos or some shit?
Like, it's...
Okay.
That's...
I'm already poisoned.
Now you're gonna give me a bestos?
Yay!
I'm poisoned.
And I have lung cancer.
Let's go.
Oh.
Wait, I missed the stone?
Stone in poison room?
Where?
These?
Oh!
Oh, these are...
Oh, I didn't realize.
I thought they were just decorations.
Alright.
Okay.
Now that I know the yellow rocks...
Alright.
Part of it.
Nice.
Wait, what the fuck?
That guy like dropped down there.
Okay.
I'm a little...
This is very high up.
This is very, very high up.
Try holy.
Striking required ahead?
Which one?
They seem like nice guys.
Oh, except for that guy.
That guy does not like me.
Is he slowly walking towards me?
I think he is.
I need magic or strike damage?
Do I...
I don't have either of that.
What is...
What is a strike thing?
I don't think I have either of that.
Is there like a material for it?
Maze?
Oh!
Does the axe help?
I have these.
Look under...
Oh!
Oh, there it is!
I'll just use this.
Alright.
It's flailing time.
Bonk!
There we go.
Does anything notice?
No.
Okay, that's cool.
Yay!
Freestyle!
Okay, nice.
Works like a charm.
Yay!
Blunt Trauma!
Let's go!
Works every time.
Oh, wait.
There's something up here.
Nothing to see here.
Think they...
You're bad people?
Oh, they're just sleeping.
Okay, nice.
Ah!
What bad
message are broken!
That's fine.
I'm okay.
Alright.
These fuckers are actually so annoying.
These actual fuckers are so annoying.
This is my last blast.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Oh my god!
That's instant blood blast!
That's fine.
Why is it always tree?
I didn't know they do...
Oh my god!
You're still alive?!
Okay.
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay.
Explosion ahead.
I like the sound of that.
Oh my god!
That's what they meant!
That's what they...
Why is this not the first message?!
Why is...
Okay, poor.
That's it.
I'm mad.
Right here.
Where is it?
Liar.
And now, for here, I'll put...
Where is it?
Close quarter battle.
There we go.
Now everyone will suffer.
Nice.
I got Gris.
Polluting the timeline.
Now they will know which one's telling the truth.
And which one's telling the lie.
As it should be.
Okay.
I think I should have enough for the sword now.
Alright.
I should have enough.
Oh, okay.
I unequipped it.
Alright.
One elephant lord speaks only the truth.
The other one lies.
Yay!
What do I need?
Four level three smithing stones.
Guys, appraise my close quarter battles.
Guys.
I need you guys.
I need you guys to appraise that specific message too.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, round one.
What the fuck?
How do I get the other one?
Alright.
Here we go.
The summoning pool is now functional.
Okay.
Weeee!
You wear a paris seek target lock?
Oh.
The bat.
That's it.
The rare bow moment.
Okay.
Here we go.
That's okay, right?
Alright.
Never mind.
I thought he would, you know.
Apparently he's struggling right now.
Get out of here.
Leave!
Oh shit.
More bats.
That's right.
Kill your kids!
Yeah!
That's right!
Kill your children!
Now what you gonna do?
You spent all those years raising those kids.
Just for them to die.
That's fucking right.
Hehehe.
Not a bad person.
We just have a...
Bat issue.
Look, they're invasive species, okay?
Killing them was like...
Basically helping the environment.
I'm just helping the environment right now.
The bloodline must end.
Exactly.
Ladder ahead?
Oh, can I...
Do I have to go down?
Do I have to?
But there's an up!
Wait, is there an up?
Yeah.
What's up?
Why down when there's an up?
Oh, down is loot?
Okay.
Okay, yes down then.
Oh, up is progress.
Down is loot.
Oh, I see.
Precious item ahead?
Oh, this thing.
Hey.
Oh.
I thought he was gonna be mad.
What?
Where?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
It's a smithing stone!
He's just chillin'.
I don't know.
Hey there, buddy.
Working high?
Oh!
That's a good smithing stone!
Yoink!
Oh!
Oh shit!
I'm so...
That's okay.
I know he can't climb ladders.
We're fine.
I'll get over it.
It's not like I...
He was gonna use that to feed his family or anything.
You were in a pack?
We're in a head?
Where?
Oh, this one?
Ha ha ha!
Get out of here!
That's right!
Oh, nice.
Marshmissing stone.
What?
In a short range battle ahead?
Oh, these guys?
Oh.
That's fine.
Wait, what?
Pew!
That's right.
I'm gonna punch you.
I'll punch you.
That's right.
Oh shit!
Okay, maybe I should...
Oh!
Maybe I should have punched!
There you go.
Okay, I might have been a little too cocky there.
I got...
Straight...
And...
Okay.
I got a...
Too wild.
Okay.
This be good fortune?
Punch the bat, Batman!
Just like Batman, I don't kill.
I just get blunt trauma.
To this...
Oh shit!
Wait, you're...
Oh!
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
No, I...
Poison.
Oh, so that's what they meant when they said use range.
But you sing so good!
Okay, I get it now.
I get it now.
I understand.
I didn't realize he was...
He was evil.
I thought he was friendly.
He seemed very friendly shaped.
Alright, now I'm poisoned again.
God dammit.
I don't know.
They were singing!
It was beautiful!
I was like enjoying the song!
It was so beautiful!
Oops.
Alright, off I go.
That was a beautiful song!
I was enjoying it.
Item head and jumping required?
Oh, this guy?
Does he give you item?
Oh, he...
OH!
Okay.
Bye.
The fuck is the item?
Enemy?
Oh, thank you.
I...
I wouldn't have known.
Oh my god!
I thought...
I thought that jump would dodge it.
The fuck is the item?
Oh, there it is.
I mean, there's the bat.
Where's this item?
Visions of item?
Oh, this one?
You know what?
Jump...
Okay, I don't think that's the jump.
It's so beautiful!
What the fuck?
Where is it?
First off, ladder.
Oh!
This one?
Okay, there's one, two, three, or four.
Oh, a lot of people died here, though.
I don't know about that.
Hmm...
Was it worth it?
Yeah, I'll do ladder first.
It doesn't seem worth it.
Alright, I'm going up first.
It definitely doesn't seem worth it.
I saw so many bloodstains, and I was like, I'm not adding myself to that.
Armments ahead?
Alright.
Oh, that's a big guy.
Why is it always...
This is a good item!
Why are you complaining?!
Alright.
Armments ahead.
Oh, I assume it's that guy.
What?!
He, like, fucking slam dunked me down.
Hmm...
Huh...
That's a big tumor.
Okay, I killed this kid.
I don't know if he likes it.
Okay, he definitely didn't like it.
Alright, jellyfish tap.
Oh, I can't do jellyfish.
Oh, okay, guys.
I can't do jellyfish.
That's okay.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
Guys, I think he's angry.
Oh, my God!
I do nothing?!
Oh, I have to hit that.
What the fuck did I fucking beat up?!
Like, where is your fucking...
Where is it?!
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I was like, where the fuck is your mouth?!
I couldn't tell!
There it is.
I got it!
Okay, octopus thing.
Okay, smithing stone.
Yeah!
Ooh!
That looks nice.
Alright, now he's asleep forever.
Alright, we go this way.
I almost walked off the bridge.
I thought I was so safe.
I...
I was like, this feels safe.
Alright, now I can summon the octopus.
Ah!
No more singing for you!
That's right!
Ha ha ha!
Alright, now we got...
I deal with her.
As long as she doesn't throw poison at...
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
That's fine.
Oh, he's old.
Nice.
Oh, it's a golden rune.
We need that.
Easy.
Oh shit, there's more of the grannies.
Oh shit, magic grannies!
Okay, now I definitely know that's cheating.
That's fine.
My jellyfish has got this.
Oh shit!
That was so much HP!
That actually one shot of me!
I've never seen that move before!
Oh my god!
She fucking gripped me!
I was expecting that!
I'll kill her first.
And then I'll deal with this guy.
Okay.
Alright, I was not expecting...
The...
The granny to grip me.
And then children.
And then...
Mommy and daddy.
Next.
There you go.
Oh my god!
Those were some grippers.
Alright.
There were so many runes too!
Okay.
Aw, the worst part is that she guards the other ladder.
That's the worst part.
Alright.
Yeah, I gotta kill them one by one.
How the fuck did I get that?
God dammit!
Okay.
Let's see if I can craft more arrows.
Okay, I can.
Good.
Alright.
One down.
Ah!
Ow!
It was sick.
Bro, they just came out of nowhere!
I was trying to aim!
Alright.
Okay.
That...
Like...
I was not expecting that.
Okay, I'll grab these two first.
Alright, and then...
Wait, she stopped singing.
Wait, that's not good.
That's not good.
She stopped singing.
Oh my god.
Stupid fucking poison granny.
God dammit!
I hate you!
No wonder your kids don't visit you anymore.
There's a reason why your kids don't love you!
God, I hate poison granny.
I hate her.
She's not even one of the cool grannies either.
There.
That's right.
This is why none of your kids wanna see you!
Oh!
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Don't get gripped.
Nice.
Alright.
Up the ladder I go.
Up, up, up.
I hope I can get my runes.
I hope I can get my runes in time.
Alright.
One down.
Whoa!
Two down.
Numeral three!
That's right, I got you!
Boom!
Okay.
Alright, it was embarrassing for both of us.
Alright.
Easy.
Up I go.
Yes, that's why it's embarrassing for both of us.
We both fucked up.
Alright, I believe in you jellyfish.
But let me grab this first in case I don't.
Alright.
Yeah.
Let me...
If I kill these guys, they won't notice, right?
Let's stay here first.
Okay, they don't notice.
That's good.
I just wanna make sure they don't...
They don't notice.
Guys, I think they notice.
Guys, I definitely think they notice, guys.
I...
I think...
No, I can do this!
I can kill them!
I believe!
Okay, jellyfish, why are you running away?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, it's that poison granny again.
It's her!
Oh my god, and magic?!
Oh god, oh no.
I didn't realize she had magic too.
I didn't realize she had everything.
Oh nice, nice interruption.
Oh my god, what if she just falls down?
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Fly back up?
Guys, she's flying back up.
I didn't expect that.
Guys, I can't believe it.
She flew back up.
There we go.
Oh, we did it.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
More smithy stone.
We need that.
How did she...
Did she die to her own poison?
Precious item ahead.
Oh, I guess like in front of me.
Oh, my jelly poisoned her.
Forgot that he does that.
Praise here.
Nice.
Oh, Jimmy forgot my jellyfish can do that.
I...
I just been using her for like...
To like face tank.
I've...
Honestly.
She was just my face tanker.
I didn't realize she was more than that.
We'll use that so I can level up.
Alright.
Dexterity?
Vigor?
Or...
Or arcane?
Chat.
Which one?
Which one, guys?
Vigor?
Okay.
Wait.
Or...
Or dexterity.
When did I upgrade last time?
I don't remember.
Alright.
I'll do Vigor.
And then I'll do dexterity next.
Oh, I should...
Yeah.
I'll do...
Uh...
Dexterity next time.
Dragon ahead?
Oh.
I like that.
Wait.
I think I can upgrade my sword again.
I'm pretty sure.
I got so many stones.
I must have...
Oh, wait.
Gotta talk to Two Toes right here.
Hello.
You have returned.
What is it?
Uh...
Do we want...
Remembrance?
Or champions?
I don't know what this is for.
Remembrance?
Oh, I can do both?
Oh.
Reach up and provide one power once the remembrance will be lost.
What does it do?
Oh!
I get to have, like, her sword and stuff.
Is it worth it?
How about this?
Are any of these worth it?
Oh my god.
7,000?
Boss weapons?
Is it worth it?
Not worth it for your build?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Bye.
Oh, it's just for cosplay?
It's just cosplay.
Alright.
Let's upgrade my sword.
Uh...
Oh, I...
Oh, I don't have enough.
Wait, do I?
No, I need four.
I only have two.
God damn it!
I don't have enough anyway.
What about my jellyfish?
I don't have enough either.
Fuck!
Alright.
Yes, I leave.
Yes, I leave then.
It's time to fight.
Oh, fuck, not here.
I got lost.
Uh...
Here.
Oh, I can use my boss's?
How do I sell that?
Oh, this?
How much does it give?
Should I use it?
Is it worth using them?
How come some people are saying it's not worth it?
Why are some people saying save them?
Save it for what?
Wait, what?
Why would I need to save them?
How do you dupe them?
Oh, in case you...
Haha, I'm not changing builds.
You think I'm gonna be a nerd?
Fuck no.
You know which one I'm definitely gonna pop?
Hers!
Get out!
Oh, wait.
Use Remembrance of the Full Moon Queen?
Wait, what?
Do I just use it here?
That's right!
Watch this!
Boom!
No more nerds now!
That's right!
Alright, now I'll grab this.
Get out of there, nerds!
Magic's for pussies!
Nerd obliterated!
As it should!
Nerd!
Alright, that does.
Alright, Dexterity or Vigor chat?
Depths 45!
Yeah, but I didn't die to the nerd!
I'd die to the real gamers!
The bats!
Alright, Vigor.
Okay.
Alright, let's go forward.
Beware a raptor, dragon, a head, monster, a head.
Pfff!
Easy.
Watch this.
First off.
Let's see ya.
Help me!
Okay, wait, let me see what he did.
Revenge!
Alright, I'm ready.
Okay, where is he?
I know this is not a...
I...
I can't seem to find the story bosses, apparently, because there's no cutscene.
And they've killed like two non-story bosses so far.
Oh my god.
He's slowly heading towards me, isn't he?
Wait, what do you mean good luck?
Guys, what the fuck do you mean?
How bad is it?
How...
Oh my god!
I don't know why I walked into it.
I don't know why.
I just wanted to be inside.
Oh!
What?
No!
Oh, I did accidentally have the wrong clasp.
Okay, thank god.
Thank god.
Okay.
Alright, I thought I fucked up, but I didn't.
That's good.
Jesus Christ, my jellyfish is not having a good time.
Are you serious?
Oh, it's the tail!
Oh, that's what the tail does!
Okay, I know now.
Who the fuck gave this lizard a sword?
It got this lizard to touch me and it hit me!
Okay, nice.
I'm just gonna recharge real quick.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna fucking, like, slam dunk me again.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He did slam dunk me!
Bro, he can walk?
Can he sing too?
I can- Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, my poor guy.
Oh my god, I'm fucking- I'm greedy.
I don't know why I'm always greedy.
Oh!
Please!
Holy shit!
You're so- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
Thank fucking god!
Okay, we did it.
Okay, it wasn't that bad.
It was not that bad.
Thank god.
Close crystal.
No strong, bro!
Actually, hey.
Good.
That was a good message.
That's a good message.
You're right.
Alright.
That's so easy.
Alright, let's see.
It's time to level up.
I'll do Dexterity and Vigor.
Am I severely under level?
How did I get here?
How-
Well done.
Oh, wait.
It's the influencer build.
I think it's actually gonna fuck me over long-term.
Think carefully and then regret.
Try jumping?
Okay.
Dude.
Where is it?
Action.
Oh, where is it?
Where's the- Where's the try jumping?
Is the jump?
I also want to tell him to jump.
Down.
There we go.
Go down.
Alright.
From?
Alright, remember to upload that.
And upload the next- The other guy that says try jumping.
Guys, remember to upload those two messages.
Then we're gonna get them.
Um.
Hey, Dookie.
Not sure if anybody has said this yet.
But hold down the button for a sec.
It takes you to the first slot.
Which is your healing class.
Thank you to the super chat for it.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, that's helpful.
That's something I keep forgetting to do.
Get- Oh, fuck!
Alright.
Okay, I need to find this thing.
Item.
Okay, remember to upload our two messages, guys.
And then- And then make sure- And then make sure you- You say pour on this one.
Alright.
Make sure you put pour for this message.
And then appraise these two messages, guys.
Then we'll get them.
We'll get them all.
Tell them all what I did, Eagle.
Tell them all.
Alright.
I don't think I've done a story boss yet.
I don't even know where is a story boss.
Alright, it's time to Skyrim this rock.
Where am I?
Is there a way to get mad for this area?
This way?
I don't even know where I am.
I'm so lost.
This guy seems dangerous, so I'm gonna ignore him.
I guess I'll go this way?
Okay.
Yeah, I killed like three non-story bosses so far.
Oh, there is a Grace here.
Nice.
That's good.
Good to know.
Yay!
There's a map?
Oh, I don't see an area to get a map, though.
Are you sure?
What's killed it?
What's that?
Oh my god!
I knew he was good.
I'm gonna steal your item!
No!
I'm sorry!
I guess I'm not.
I guess I'm not gonna steal the item.
You see?
I guess, because you can have it.
I guess.
I don't need it.
Guys, I don't need it, I swear.
Hello.
Ooh!
Ha ha ha.
That's looking right.
Get circled.
Oh, what?
Oh my gosh, he ran back.
Get juked.
Ha ha ha.
Where's Candid?
The fuck is that?
Wait, what?
I get to talk to my girlfriend?
Hello.
Hello, my lady.
The earth tree is close.
Only a little further till the foot of the earth tree.
Ahead east from the starting area?
Alright.
Mox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you're having spun it off, guy.
I'm sorry.
I still have a panel tomorrow, so you can see me there.
I have to ascertain for myself the reason for which I live.
Burned.
And bodiless.
Alright.
Is that it?
That's all I have to say?
Alright.
Bye, girlfriend.
I guess that was just lore.
Where?
To, like, here?
Or is it here?
Did I go here?
From...
The starting area?
Kaelin is fun.
Me when I lie.
Guys.
Is it not actually fun, guys?
I have a feeling it might not actually is fun.
Is it poison?
Oh, my God.
Is it poison, guys?
Are you taking me to poison swamps?
Is it even better?
Oh, my...
You think I don't know what Scarlet Rot is?
That's the whole Melania shit.
Oh, my God!
Where did he come from?
Okay.
That's it.
Jellyfish.
Oh, wait.
I know this boss.
That's a Night Ring.
This boss is a Night Ring.
I've seen him.
It was just flying, Doki.
Oh, my God.
That still hits me.
I thought...
I don't know.
I thought I was being so cool.
I thought I was gonna, you know...
Dodge the fucking fire.
Just, you know...
Oh, my God!
I...
No!
Fuck!
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm...
That's not fine.
I'm trying so hard to get his legs.
I really am.
I swear to God.
I swear to God!
It's not...
Oh, my God!
It's not letting me lock into anything, apparently!
I can't lock in anything!
Okay, we can wait here.
Okay, apparently not.
What is your range?
Oh, don't lock in.
It's better?
Okay.
I know now.
I got a rock.
To block it all.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
Alright.
Oh, my God!
Not the fire!
He's flying away!
You cheater!
Get back here!
Fight me!
You chose this fight!
I was literally minding my own business!
Oh!
Shit!
What?!
How can you be so big, but so hard to hit?!
I don't understand!
Oh, my God!
You actually fight like a pussy!
You...
You actually fight like a fucking pussy!
I...
Oh, I hate this man.
I hate this dragon.
He's so big, yet so hard to hit!
Like, I don't understand!
Oh, my God!
Where are you going?!
It's okay.
I have a rock.
Oh, my God.
I'll just let you die from poison.
Fuck this.
I hope you're happy.
I hope you're happy now.
That's right.
Die from poison!
You deserve it!
Die from the slowest death possible!
That's fucking red!
I'm...
I can wait!
That's red!
Oh, my God!
Okay, that was my bad.
I thought rock will save me.
Apparently not.
Don't fuck this.
Oh, my God.
Fuck me, I guess.
That's right!
Die from poison!
I can wait!
I did it.
Fuck you!
Your death was pathetic.
Thanks for your heart.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
See, guys.
I win in the end.
Alright.
I'm back.
I win.
We take this.
In the ruins?
Here?
Oh, I know this.
This was in the night rain.
I know this area.
Oh, shit.
Is it?
Do I go here?
There's caves?
I'm trying to find the cave.
Wait, what?
My God fucking...
There's no summons here.
Oh!
Go to the castle to farm...
Oh, it's an NPC.
Okay.
I got really scared.
I...
AHHHHH!
Okay.
I was like...
Wait.
How...
How can you invade?
I was gonna be so worried.
I was like, there's no way you can invade.
There was no way you could invade.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We got him.
Oh, thank God.
Nice.
Okay.
That's good.
I was like...
How did you...
How did you get here?
I didn't...
I didn't summon dragons just so I could avoid being invaded.
Oh, there's a cave now.
Oh.
I'm in the murk water cave.
All right.
I can use this dagger.
Yeah, but is it better than what I have now, though?
Group ahead.
No summoning, so to speak.
Levels, sword ahead.
Best friends game?
Oh my God.
Friends?
I don't think he knows.
Guys, I think he knows.
Oh, I'm definitely in the over level for this.
Wait, what?
How would he use the bell?
Wait.
Where the fuck is the bell coming from?
I'm gonna fuck this guy.
Who's ringing the bell right now?
No.
Kill them all.
Oh, it's a trip wire.
Expecto, dear.
Wait, did I just come from here?
No, I came from...
Ooh.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's just moss.
Weak foe ahead.
Lover ahead.
Ooh, lover!
Hello, lady.
Hello.
Any maidens?
Hello?
Maiden?
Oh, am I gonna get fear in?
Like, what?
Can I just hit it?
I'm not...
You can tell this is a trap!
Like, what else?
Oh.
Oh, it's not.
Oh, it wasn't a trap.
Oh.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, it's...
Oh, it's Patches!
Oh, my God!
Wait, you're here?
Wait, Patches?
Oh, my God!
I...
Goodbye, Patches!
Go back to Bloodborne!
Oh, yeah, nice.
Oh, dang, you killed him.
Oh.
Whoops.
Oh, I...
Guys, I was too strong.
I was a little too strong.
I died.
Whoops.
Okay!
It took me four hits!
How was I supposed to know?
You could have said that before I killed...
Before I did four hits on him.
I...
You know I don't wait.
I kill first, then ask questions later.
Rest in peace, Patches, Bloodline.
He leered.
Okay!
We all saw him!
He's trying to stab me first!
He...
He started it!
Whoops.
Um...
Guess we're not getting Patches.
I'm not saying I deserve that because at least I made him grovel and kiss your feet first.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well...
That's unlucky.
It's alright.
How...
Can't be that important.
It's Patches.
Right, guys?
Can't be that important, guys.
Right?
It's Patches.
Is it really that important if it's Patches, though?
I can't believe it.
It's fine.
You're all so weak, anyway.
Like, what is he gonna do, anyway?
Betray me?
Like, all L the others?
That's all they do.
He was just gonna betray me, and you know it.
Alright.
Wait, where...
Oh my gosh, I'm...
Oh, I can revive him with a turtle pup?
Don't worry.
The pup will save me.
He'll forgive me.
All will be forgiven.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Turtle pup will save me.
He'll surely forgive me.
Wait, can I actually...
Oh, wait.
I can't?
What's the point of having a poop if you can't revive him?
Oh, we gotta go now.
Guys, I remember what he did in Bloodborne.
I'm sorry.
I remember...
But I...
I never forget.
Exactly.
It's not a sin to kill Patches, guys.
It's Patches.
Oh yeah.
Never forget.
You fought Nereus and survived.
That alone deserves commendation.
I am you.
Hunter of bloody fingers.
Tarnished.
Held in thrall by cessblood.
Zealots.
What was his path sin?
By being Patches.
You're certain to face more of them.
Just remember...
No kinship with their elk remains.
Their madness precludes it.
Don't let your emotions stay oblade.
Huh?
Be on your way.
Perhaps we will meet.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Nice talk.
Where am I?
I guess I'll head east still.
Oh, item!
Yay!
What's that?
Wait, oh.
I bet they're weak though.
Yeah.
I'm way too over level for this area.
For sure.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Why is that so tanky?
Oh...
They get rezzed.
Do I have to...
Oh my god!
Okay, give me a sec guys.
There's too many of you!
Okay, I have to double hit them.
Oh, they're the double hitters.
I see.
It's the double hitters.
But it's okay.
I can just get this guy up first.
Okay.
That's fine.
They are weak.
I just forgot that these guys can get revived.
Spirit jumping.
Oh.
Okay.
Press A after that.
Okay, that's the other cave.
Jesus fucking Christ!
Oh my god!
It was too short!
It's too short!
Look at him!
He's cheating!
He's actually...
He's like...
Fucking on the ground!
He's actually cheating.
Like...
What the fuck is that?
Alright, it's fine.
I...
Just fuck her.
That's...
Oh my god!
And then the mosquito just was like, I want to join too.
Alright, where are you?
Where are you?
Get out of here!
Try fire?
Oh, is it on these guys?
Oh, I don't have any fire weapon though.
Let's...
Let's start wailing them.
I don't really have anything else to do.
I don't.
I don't have...
Unfortunately.
Man.
Alright.
I know the pattern though.
I figured it out.
God, there's so many.
Wait.
Can I just use a torch on them?
Okay, I'll try.
Oh.
Okay.
Does it do anything?
Guys, I don't think it does anything.
Guys.
Yeah, that did not do anything.
Let me just...
Let me just keep using this weapon.
I have a feeling that did nothing.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill this track.
I...
Oh.
Here we go.
Am I two-handed?
I don't think I can two-handed yet.
Yeah.
No.
It's useless.
The regular...
The regular katana does more.
Just from bleed alone.
No, the katana does more.
Just from the bleed in general.
No door ahead.
What do you mean?
Oh, it's a dungeon!
Nice.
Oh, it might be a really weak dungeon too.
The dagger?
Was the dagger really better than my katana though?
My katana is just so much better in general.
Oh yeah, me.
I can upgrade again.
I'll use two.
I think it's like...
400.
Right?
Mixed up bleed fast?
Alright, I'll try it out.
Oh, it's 12k.
Okay.
Yeah, you need to use two.
Alright, there we go.
Uh...
Bigger.
Okay, I'll try it out.
Inventory.
Equipment.
I'll try it out.
Is it called?
This one?
Wait, I'm not...
What do I need for it?
Oh, I need arcane.
I don't have enough arcane though.
Guys.
That's you, bitch.
That's right.
Haha, I saw you.
Oh my god.
You shouldn't be allowed to- OH MY GOD!
Bro!
Did anyone get the license plate?
There's more of you!
Guys!
What was the license plate?
I didn't even call the police.
Alright.
We're fine.
Tom, do you have a super shot?
Do you think?
Oh, I'm glad you like the mod!
The new skin suit!
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Actually, get out of here.
I know there's one more.
I'm just- That's fine.
Boom.
Okay, I need to get this item out though.
Yeah, the roll is too fat.
What's this do?
Oh.
Okay, I already unlocked the boss room.
Oh, that's easy.
What?
Oh, it's a trap!
Wait, do I have a lance equipped?
Why do I have a lance equipped, guys?
Oh, you mean the shield?
Oh, damn.
Beware of a trap.
Oh, this must be a trap.
That's right.
You don't- Okay, nevermind.
Okay, you might- Okay, okay.
Oh!
I got- I got ganked in the alleyway.
I went- I went into murder alleyway.
And got fucking Bruce Wayne.
I got- I went into murder- Crime alley.
Fucking goddamn crime alley.
Oh my god, I hate these guys.
I- I- Oh my god.
I hate all of them.
Get out of here.
Okay, I'm getting my stuff back.
Stupid crime alley.
I can't believe it's happening again!
Oh my god!
Why are you so fast?!
It's okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm- I'm so healthy.
Alright, time to fight him.
I'm- I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Try two-handing and then try jump attack, alright?
I survived.
My death was over-exaggerated.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
Guys, I wanted to- I wanted to try the two-hand, okay?
That's fucking right.
Ha ha ha!
I'm so over-leveled!
Ha ha ha ha!
That's right!
I'm so over-leveled!
Yeah!
Ha ha ha ha!
Easy.
Alright.
Are there any items here?
Ha ha ha!
You can't do nothing about that.
Oh my god, I killed so many bosses and none of them were the story bosses.
Oh my god, he only give 2k!
That's how under-leveled he was.
The goblins were so much harder.
No, it's true.
They were.
Oh no.
Not these guys.
Yeah, I gotta go here.
Whee!
Oh hey, Grace!
I actually need that.
Let me kill these guys for more arrows though.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Oh my god, you think you'll live?
Just cause I missed my first slash?
Ha ha ha!
That's fucking right.
Give me your bones.
Oh?
Oh, I got the painting.
Tranquility.
Oh, wait.
Where's the Grace?
Oh, there.
There it is.
Uh...
Let's get healed real fast.
Let's see.
Oh wait, is this where you get the map?
Is that it?
That's where you get the next map, right?
I'll go to that big tree right here?
Yeah, I'm trying to...
I wanna get to this map.
Okay.
Guys, I'm getting better at the Elden Ring.
Whee!
Let's get my solos back.
It didn't look that high.
I don't know.
I thought...
I thought it looked perfectly...
It looked like a normal jump.
That's...
There we go.
At least that worked.
It looked like such a normal jump.
I thought my horse could take it.
You know?
I thought I could Yoshi it.
I don't know why.
It looked so Yoshi-able.
Oh.
Alright.
This should be where the map is.
We're almost there.
Wait, is that a boss?
Are you a boss or a regular guy?
Oh.
Oh no, they're regular.
There's like five of them up around me.
Okay.
Okay, they're just regular people.
Alright, we got the map.
Map found.
I guess...
Oh, that looks like a scarlet area.
That...
Yeah, that looks like a scarlet area.
Wait, what's this?
Riverwell?
What is this?
Oh.
It's so pretty!
What is this area?
It's really pretty, though.
Oh, it's very, very deep.
Yeah, the longest elevator in the world.
There should be some elevator music.
How far does it go?
What the fuck?
There's still more?!
Wait, is this...
Oh my god, I don't know if I like this area anymore.
It seems...
Feels like there's a lot of things that's gonna be hiding.
Oh, thank god, there's a graze here.
Dung required a head?
Wait, why?
What?
He's pretty!
Look up?
Look up where?
That?
What am I looking up for?
Oh, just a nice view.
I was like...
Is there something here?
Oh...
Is there a boss here?
Oh, nice.
Runes.
Oh...
Where are the enemies?
More runes.
Yippee!
Hmm...
Try horseback battle?
For what?
Why?
Oh, there's a guy right here.
Somebody's trying horseback battles right now.
Oh...
These guys.
Now I can take them.
I don't need to try some...
Watch this!
Oh...
Oh, wait.
Wait, they're really tanky.
Wait a minute.
Wait, are these like...
Do I need the mace for this, guys?
Guys, do I need the mace?
For this?
Yeah, they look like stone people.
Alright, give me a sec.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got this.
I'm just swapping weapons real quick.
That's right.
Now I'm ready to smash!
Who are they?
That's right.
I'm ready.
Boom!
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
That...
Does not do that much damage.
Um...
Hmm...
Alright, I'm just gonna ride...
You know what?
They were right.
Let me just ride past them.
Maybe...
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Goodbye.
Hey, what's over here?
Why do I get up there?
Oh, it's like... I jumped.
Goodbye.
Bye-bye.
Oh!
Oh my god, he just stabbed me like that.
Jesus Christ!
There's so many of them!
Oh my...
Thank god I didn't try to fight these guys.
There were way too many.
Nice, we needed that.
Oh wait!
There was something up here.
Okay, we got a horn.
Whoops!
Did not mean to fall.
Oh hey!
Nice!
Actually.
I did mean to fall.
Okay, thank god they're like super slow too.
Whoop!
Alright.
And then we grab this one.
Ooh!
Rainbow!
I like that.
Alright, is there any more items here?
They're like parkour.
Yeah, I was gonna say the parkour items.
Okay, but how do I parkour this?
I assume it's like here.
No!
Oh, I wish you could like steady your horse.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like...
Oh, this is so hard to control.
Oh, man!
This is actually so hard to control, guys.
Oh, if you like spell...
Oh, okay.
I don't.
Never mind.
It's not worth it.
It's for the nerds.
I ain't no nerd.
We don't need that.
It's okay, guys.
I ain't no nerd.
Filthy magic.
Hahaha.
Seek item?
You guys were like being like, Oh, just get out.
Just don't use torrent.
And I was like, who the fuck is torrent?
I forgot that's his name.
Hahaha.
You see, I made sure to make him name this so I...
So I can dehumanize him even more.
I forgot.
That you know him bad.
Therefore praise this message.
Horse?
What about horse?
I just call him horse.
That's my name for him.
He's just horse.
I think that's a great name.
Honestly.
It's like when people name their...
Name their dog, dog.
But then like, I get the name.
By name my goat, horse.
You wear a crab?
What's wrong with this crab?
Oh, this crab?
Okay, let me...
Oh!
I didn't even notice I had my fist up.
Buzz land.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
No, he couldn't have that.
Goodbye.
That's alright.
Wait.
Unless...
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
He has the last laugh.
Never mind.
One more hit.
There we go.
How much do I get out of that?
Was it even worth it?
Oh my god.
It was so worth it.
He gave me 2,000 and I stole his children.
Praise the giant sword.
Crabs don't care about high ground.
Oh, okay.
That's pretty.
I will admit.
That is really pretty.
Yeah.
Anything here?
Oh, there's some grace.
Nice.
Yay.
Oh.
Oh, look at all these beautiful deers.
Look at them.
And these beautiful deers for me to kill.
Ha ha ha.
Yeah, I think.
Kill crab.
Please.
I'm sorry.
Please have mercy.
Please.
I didn't mean it.
I wasn't.
I didn't.
When I say kill.
I mean like.
Kiss.
Ha ha ha.
Sorry.
I think that's just my first language.
I got confused.
I just wanted to kiss the crab.
Yay.
Okay.
We can kill them.
Ha ha.
JK.
I actually wanted to kill the crab.
Where do I go?
This air is.
This air is so big.
Like, there's no actual map arena here.
Wait.
That's a ghost.
How do I kill a ghost?
Wait.
Those are ghosts.
You could kill a ghost?
Is he an evil ghost?
Oh my god.
Ha ha.
Guys.
I think that's an evil ghost, guys.
Wait.
But I'm normal type.
Oh wait.
But he's a weak.
Never mind.
Apparently he's weak against normal.
That stupid ghost.
Okay.
Nice.
I guess I'll go up.
Oh nice.
That does so much too.
That's good.
That's good to know.
Alright.
I'm too lazy to reinstall.
Log into praise.
But here's some support anyway.
I think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
I'll just go up.
What?
I'm not invading anything.
I'm just exploring.
I'm Christopher Columbus.
It's not like we were...
It's not like we removed his statue or anything.
What's this?
Oh!
Wow!
Oh nice.
That's a great...
I touched up.
Alright.
What does that do?
What did I even do?
Is that part of the mission?
Normal type is immune to ghost type.
I have to light them all up?
Oh.
Okay.
This is part of this quest.
Oh my god!
He fli- Oh my god!
He cheated!
Oh no!
Oh yeah.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I got greedy.
But that's okay.
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
You were- Oh thank you.
Thank you.
Oh man.
That was so helpful.
That great rune.
Jesus Christ.
I have to find eight of these?
What's he doing?
Protecting that.
Wait.
Can I backstab a ghost?
Backshot it.
Backshot it a ghost.
That's right.
You ain't finding peace in the afterlife.
What was he doing in the corner?
It wasn't even a surprise attack.
It was just there.
I'll grab this.
Okay.
Oh it's these guys again.
Is it even worth it?
No they're not.
It's plus 27.
Maybe the big guy?
Maybe the- Nah.
I don't think it's worth it actually.
Wait.
What are these guys doing here?
Are these guys worth it?
I have no idea they're worth it.
Oh.
That's poison.
We're just chillin.
Fuck these flowers I guess.
It's like I'm the Mr. Beast villain.
Where he's trying to- Did you guys see that thing?
Where like.
He used to be all about planting trees.
And like.
And saving the ocean.
And now he ha- He like.
Uh.
Released an AI generated thumbnail website.
From planning.
You know it's like.
All those trees I planted.
Fuck that.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Can flowers bleed?
It's time to find out.
It's time to find out if these flowers.
I thought it was crazy.
Like he was like.
The fact that like.
Now he's like.
Promoting an AI generated YouTube thumbnail website.
And then he like.
Put on like.
He like.
Put like.
Jacksepticeye in there.
Even though he was.
Jacksepticeye has been like.
Super vocal about hating AI.
I think that one was crazy.
Like he put that in the promotion.
He's done.
I got him.
Wait.
That's it?
What was the point of killing him?
How do I get up there?
Is that parkour?
Parkour.
Okay.
Come on horse.
You got this.
My god.
I've always believed.
I've always believed!
Alright.
Hello.
I know.
Oh.
A customer.
Yeah.
That's me.
Oh.
There's nothing really.
Never mind.
You don't have anything I want.
Wait.
That's it?
What the fuck was the point?
Guys.
I don't need to get soap.
I'm not at a convention.
Oh really?
Wait.
Okay.
What's the cookbook for?
Do I really need this though?
Eh.
I barely craft.
That's the thing.
Okay.
I'll buy one.
Can I go anywhere else?
Is that it?
Eh.
I guess there's nothing else here.
We don't need the keys.
Do we?
Yeah.
I don't think we need the keys.
I'm never gonna change my stats.
Do we need the keys?
What are we gonna get to them for?
Uh.
I'll get...
Eh.
I'll buy one.
Alright.
That's all I'll buy.
Goodbye.
Oh man.
I spent so much money there.
Better be worth it.
What?
I don't really like fighting these guys.
There's too...
They're not worth it.
These big boys.
I don't know.
These big boys aren't worth it in my opinion.
Cause the babies barely give anything to.
I'm not buying soap!
I'll use what mother nature gave me.
Soap is a devil's worth.
Oh wait.
There's another crab.
Wait.
Crab's good.
Crab gives me so much.
Fuck.
Every time.
I never learn.
It's fine.
I can tank this.
Here you go.
If cats can self-groom, I can.
So cute.
Thank you.
Oh shit!
Ghosts!
I'm afraid of no ghosts.
Oh my god.
Wait.
This guy is stronger than the other ghosts.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Alright.
Now I can light this up.
I'll kill these deers for fun too.
Oh wait.
Joink.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, now...
Oh!
Nice, he almost grabbed me.
That's close.
Oh god, that was close.
Oh, I don't have any...
I don't have magic anymore!
No more!
Alright, that's fine.
I'm okay.
Everything's fine.
Uh...
That's eight, right?
There's eight of these.
God, I have to find so many.
Get out.
Oh, there's so many ghosts.
There's a grace nearby?
Alright, let's find that grace first.
I don't want to find that grace.
Or anything.
Where is...
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Did I...
Okay, I refilled everything.
Alright, time to find more.
Oh, I'm only two out of eight.
How is there eight of these?
After I get all eight, do I just like unlock...
Uh, unlock the boss?
Will I ever...
Jesus Christ.
I haven't done a single story boss.
What?
I've been stuck in the...
I don't know how I haven't fucking found a single story boss.
I know this is not...
This does not look like a story boss area too.
That's the thing.
I can tell this isn't a story boss area.
I can't.
We're gonna be here forever.
I could have done two entire story bosses.
Do you think I'm, like, two under level for the story boss, though?
For the next one?
Oh, yeah.
They look like nice rats.
They were not nice rats.
They were...
Felt
like they'd be nice to me.
You know?!
Like, I'm like the exception?
Like, I don't know, maybe I'd be, like...
Remy from Ratatouille?
Oh my god.
Oh, I didn't die.
Oh, it's a miracle.
It actually is a miracle I didn't die.
Okay, well, it gave me to another shrine.
You know what?
That works out.
Oh my god, there's so many rats.
At least we found another shrine.
Calculated, guys.
Very calculated.
He doesn't know.
He's too busy, Lexi.
Doing the morning exercises, you know?
It's the morning exercise.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What?
Oh!
He doesn't stop swinging!
Jesus Christ.
Oh, he doesn't stop.
He doesn't stop.
He doesn't stop!
I can take this.
Oh, I can take it.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, look where I'm seeing you guys tomorrow on the panel.
Oh, I forgot to wake up early tomorrow, too.
Because, like, it's the only time for me to go through the Artist Alley.
So, I have to wake up at, like, so early to do it before my panel.
Thank god I'm taking three days off after.
Okay.
Where's the other thing I found?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, they're doing their morning exercises again.
Oh, the one child decided to not follow his mom.
Oh, no, he saw.
He saw me kill.
Jesus.
Okay.
Alright, I'm playing a lot more careful right now.
Alright.
I think he backstab.
Yes!
It's too late for him!
Too late, I apologize.
It's too late!
Light that candle!
Yippee!
I don't even know how many I've got.
That's right.
Backshot the ghost.
What you gonna do now?
Oh, that's for flask.
I shouldn't need that.
There's apparently a hundred boost selling Doki merch.
So I might not be able to get to a hundred.
But like, uh, I'll try to get as many as I could before I get like too tired.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, there's a lot of boost selling Doki merch.
But, uh, oh wait, is that...
Eh.
But then...
If I'm getting, if I'm too tired...
Oh my god!
Oh, they know magic too!
Ghost magic!
Holy shit!
What?!
Are they like, are they auto-aiming?
Oh my god!
Is this auto-aiming?!
This has to be auto-aiming!
There's no way!
Ghost magic!
Oh my god!
This is what the shrine does!
This...
Wait, use a key?
How do I use it?
Oh!
Did I just use...
Go to my inventory?
On the gargoyles?
Oh!
What?
Oh, I see!
What does this do?
Oh, up I go!
Up and up I go!
Hello?
Oh...
I want to go home!
That's the first message I saw!
Why would the key take me here?
Why would it take me here?
Let's go to...
Oh...
No...
Where am I?
Do I go?
I don't know where to go!
Oh...
Wait, aren't those bears like, really scary?
Like, stronger than any of the other fucking area... things?
Oh my god, I'm fucking leaving.
I'm fucking...
Oh my god!
AHHHHHH!
AHHHHH!
He did fire!
Oh my god!
Oh fuck god!
Get me outta here!
Where am I?
Holy shit!
What's this?
Oh, that's a big ass beta!
I'm gonna go kill it!
I don't know how I survived!
I'm so sad!
I don't know how I survived though!
But I'm here now!
I'm...
Oh...
That's a swamp!
Alright, how much does it do?
Oh...
No...
Not the poison!
Alright...
I...
Okay...
Goodbye...
Take me back!
Take...
Yeah...
Um...
I'm leaving!
Alright...
We'll go right side!
Surely right side is not as bad, right?
Okay, these guys look like scouters.
But they don't seem like they're evil though.
Eh...
What do they kill?
OH SHIT!
Themselves!
Okay, now I know.
Sniper ahead?
Oh, there he is.
Okay, I can outrun this.
Alright...
Um...
Oh my...
Okay, that was absolute cinema though.
That was...
Yeah man, that was pretty fucking cool.
I don't know if I can do that again though.
I can.
Absolute cinema!
Watch this.
Please jump.
Okay.
Wait...
That guy doesn't...
I don't know if that guy's friend shape.
Oh shit!
That's not what I wanted to do.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay, that was cool.
That was really...
You gotta admit.
That was pretty cool what I just did.
I opened.
Oh my god!
I was gaming!
Calculated!
Did I talk to him yet?
Or is he too mad about the guy?
Yeah, but like...
But like, I have some guys trying to kill me.
You can now see the Knight of the Red Jar Great Summon?
Done?
Where is it?
Where's his summon?
Or I guess I...
Engage...
Touch the...
Spirit Ashes or...
Oh!
It's like a little coliseum area.
Oh, okay.
So it's useless to me.
On the path behind me?
Oh, is it that?
No, that's where everybody died.
What the fuck?
How did all these people die?
I don't know, man.
How did all you guys die?
Knight of the Great Jar?
Who are these people?
Is it worth it?
Oh.
Wait, but what's the point of trying to kill them?
It's fun.
Alright, I'm leaving.
Oh my god, I can't leave because that guy is still aggro towards me!
What if I don't look at him?
Okay, apparently that doesn't work.
Oh my god, I actually can't use the map.
I actually can't leave.
Left.
I can save England and go back to the aggro, that one giant that keeps aggro- That's it, I'm gonna kill him.
I got this.
Wait, go inside and crouch?
He doesn't know.
Oh, okay, he actually did it.
Nice.
Okay, we're leaving.
I don't wanna- I don't wanna deal- Alright, where's the story boss, guys?
How do we get to the story boss?
We'll kill one story boss before I go.
It's in Kaelin?!
Okay, we're going to the bed and coffin.
Is there another story boss?
It's- Is there- Is there- Another story boss?
No.
Okay.
Back to hell we go.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom then.
Before I go through this cursed area.
I'm back.
I'm sad, but I'm back.
Getting a tab out real quick.
Alright.
Let me get back into hell.
It's back to hell I go.
Oh my god, please.
Let me tap back in.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god.
Turn back.
I feel you.
Here we go.
Back to hell.
Both sides are just as bad.
Oh god.
Wait, maybe this is how I can get this.
Nice.
What the fuck?!
What killed me?!
What?
Oh my god.
I don't even-
How many did I lost?
Guys.
How many did I lose, guys?
How many- How many souls did I lose?
I don't even know.
Oh my god.
I forgot you guys can't see it.
You guys couldn't even see it.
I don't even know how many I lost.
I don't remember.
Stupid explosion thing.
Oh my god, please don't tell me it's above me!
I swear to god, IT'S ABOVE ME!!!
Guys, if I TP, do I lose my grace?
I need a no.
Guys, before I go up.
If I TP, do I lose it?
No?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, that's all I need to know before I go back to hell.
That's good to know.
Stupid fucking bear.
I see it.
How did it go here?
Of course it wants to be as close as possible to this goddamn bear.
Oh my god.
I don't know how I survived, but I did.
I...
That's fine.
It was 7,000, by the way.
Thank god I... Thank god.
Thank god.
It was actually... It was 7,000.
I'm glad I... I'm glad I didn't risk it.
Oh my god, I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna bother.
You can... You can... You can keep it.
You can fucking keep it.
Oh my god.
I was trying to do my map.
Okay, which way is the boss, guys?
Which way?
Which way, chat?
North, South, East, West...
East.
Okay.
I go East now.
South?
Okay, I go South, East.
Oh my god, thank god there's a Grace.
In the middle of hell.
Thank... my god.
Thank god.
I found... I found a Grace.
Okay.
I might don't have enough to level up.
Oh yeah.
I definitely do.
Wait, actually... Let me double check.
1600, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
I need 5k.
Do I need 5k?
Let me double check.
Yeah, I just need 5k.
I'll just... I'll just crack open all these runes real quick.
Alright.
Okay, and then... We keep using until we get 12k.
I'm pretty sure we have just enough.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, we definitely have enough.
Okay, just one more.
Oh wait, we... Yeah, okay, there you go.
Yeah, we just had enough.
Alright.
Can we do Vigor or Dexterity chat?
Vigor or Dexterity?
More damage?
Alright.
Vigor for this area?
Okay.
I'll do Dexterity next then.
Alright.
Time to figure out where the fuck is the goddamn... Wait, what's that?
Is that it?
Oh my god!
Okay, guys!
Did you take me to a non-fucking-story boss again?
I fucking... Okay.
Goddammit.
Guys, I'll have you, no?
We're ending the stream without killing a story boss.
This is the last boss.
This is on you.
You went in there.
You guys said East!
I went East!
Okay.
I went East.
I just listened.
I listened.
I demonstrated.
I didn't... Ahhaha... Rah-aahaaah!
Rah-Eah!
Ha-haah!
And concepts!
Thank you for Magenta Super!
Thank you.
Oh my god.
He does so much!
He does so much damage!
Damn it.
Guys, I don't think I'm good enough for it.
I said for ourselves.
Alright, alright guys.
After we die, we find the story boss.
I'm not fighting him.
He's scary.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
My god.
He's very scary, guys.
I'm very scared.
He seems to know what he's doing, guys.
Holy fuck.
Guys, he definitely knows what he's doing.
Okay.
Alright.
I got two hits in off my gaming.
I guess I'm no longer gaming, guys.
Guys, I'm no longer gaming.
I'm...
At least I know his patterns.
Sorta.
Oh my god.
God, get out.
Wait, what?
What is he doing?
What are you...
They're behind me, aren't they?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I just need to...
I need to know.
Do these...
Can these...
Do these guys despawn?
Do these guys despawn before I try to kill them?
Do they despawn?
Do they...
No.
Okay.
Alright.
He summoned his squad.
Okay.
Alright.
Phase two.
Man, I wish I could summon my squad numerous times.
That'd be so cool.
Cool.
Oh my god.
Yeah, they do, Dookie.
When you kill the boss.
I wish there was friendly fire.
If only there was friendly fire.
And then they can hit each other.
Oh my god.
Of course he boosts your attack.
Of course.
Oh, look at course.
You gotta respect that the boys coming in clutch.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I stood next to the...
Goddamn.
Alright.
Which way?
I forgot.
Which way was it?
South.
East.
Okay.
So this way.
Alright.
That's South East.
Do we go through the swamp?
Or do we go up?
I'm gonna go up.
Here?
Yeah.
I know that that's where the map is.
But I'm trying to find the boss right now.
Up?
Like up here?
Or do we go through the castle?
Oh shit.
Want me to grab the map?
Oh I can't look at it.
Is this the cliff?
Oh hey.
Here.
What's here?
Vision's a cliff.
Yeah.
I'm not going down there.
You can't trick me.
I can't...
Wait.
I don't know.
Maybe if I'm...
Maybe if I'm very, very quiet.
I figure out how to get down.
Oh is that the boss area?
How do you get down?
Oh do we go back to the castle?
Okay.
Alright.
We try to go to the castle.
Okay.
That's not self guys.
Self is this way.
Assume it's here.
Oh not this way?
Oh that's not the right castle.
Other...
There's another castle?
Where's the other castle?
Is this way?
I'm self.
Oh hey there's a merchant.
Hello.
Wait where's the merchant?
It's just a...
Oh there he is.
There's more than one castle?
Oh there you go.
Okay so I just go down.
From here.
Oh that's a lot of dogs.
I don't think they look friendly guys.
They definitely do not look friendly.
Wait where's the map?
Wait I missed the map.
Oh it's right here.
I see it.
I see it's behind me isn't it?
Oh I got golden seed though.
That was worth it.
Like right here somewhere.
It's like here?
Hello?
Map Doko?
Oh there it is.
I see it.
This is literally right behind me.
Okay there we go.
Oh is this castle?
Right here?
Okay.
Get rid of all...
Okay I wanna get rid of all my fucking...
thing.
Okay so I just have to go here.
Alright.
Here we go.
We're gonna make it...
All the way to the other side.
Alright.
How under level am I for this boss though?
I...
I got sent out.
How fucked am I?
He's pretty tough.
Alright guys if we...
Oh my god.
The wall.
My biggest enemy.
Oh hey there's a portal.
Yes.
Wait are they fighting each other?
Oh I can get more flask.
Yes.
Yay.
Alright.
Time to touch the portal.
Boop.
I hear how...
I always have that unimpressed high expression.
Alright thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait I made it.
Oh that was easy.
I'm here.
Now where do I go?
Did I get to that castle?
Here?
There's two paths.
There's two wolves inside me.
I guess I'll go this way.
I see Grace here.
Yay.
Alright.
Guess we go here.
Are they friendly?
Oh friendly!
Oh!
There are two wolves!
I caught it!
Where's wolf number two?
Allow me to introduce myself.
Live.
We find ourselves pitted against Radan.
I'm gonna...
Okay I'm gonna be like...
I'm not AFK.
I'm just ordering food.
Cause I'm like...
Oh shit it's late.
Huh?
Oh isn't that the wolf that everyone wants to fuck?
That's that wolf right?
The bang wolf?
Alright.
Ooh.
Okay.
I'm gonna get...
BBQ beef.
And...
BBQ...
Lamb.
Cool.
You know those like...
Chinese...
Like skewers?
I love those.
They're so good.
Grabbing the beef and lamb one.
I haven't had those in a long time.
Let's see what else should I get.
Hmm.
Uh...
Show this to Bob.
Watch her go crazy.
I saw like...
You know how like...
You can see like tweets from...
Your followers.
Like people you follow.
Like the replies and stuff.
And then someone was cosplaying that wolf guy from the...
What was it?
ZZZ.
And I saw her reply to one of them.
And was like...
Uh...
Are you single?
I saw that.
Alright.
See I think that's all I wanna order.
That's already a lot of food.
Cause there's like five skewers for each.
Uh...
Is that really all I wanna order?
Yeah.
Alright.
Quest utensils.
It's too late to like make anything.
Alright.
Nice.
C'mon.
Gimme my food.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'm back.
Champions.
That's me.
Hello.
The stars have aligned.
The festival is nigh.
Uh...
Time for...
Oh hey friend!
My dear's demigod of the shattering awaits you.
Champions.
Prepare for battle.
I'm so ready.
Wait and...
That's him!
I see him in memes!
Yay!
I'm so ready for the festival.
Are you ready for the festival guys?
People say that one day I'll be the Elden Lord.
Oh boy.
If it isn't a tarnished warrior.
I am the warrior jar.
Iron fist Alexander.
The pleasure is mine.
Hello Alexander.
I saw your dad.
This festival is being held.
Well...
It is none other than General Radahn himself to think.
I could face a great champion of the shattering.
A demigod in the flesh.
Oh gosh.
In truth, I quiver at the thought.
Such is his frightful repute.
But, the fear simply assures me the ordeal is worth undertaking.
Be sure to get a good vantage my friend.
I, Iron Fist Alexander, do hereby vow to unflinchingly brave this ordeal.
Oh.
I got this.
Don't worry guys.
Don't worry Alexander.
I'll prove to you all.
First off.
That I deserve the title of Eldendorn.
Give up.
Alright, I'm ready.
That message is for future Doki.
That's for future Doki to see.
When I get back here.
Are you good and prepared young chum?
Yeah, I'm so ready.
The festival begins.
Ready as I'll ever be.
Before we begin.
Allow me to paint you.
Oh shit.
Wait, it's this guy.
Wait, I know this cutscene.
I've seen this cutscene before.
Oh fuck.
I have to lower the difficulty.
Why did you guys bring me to this one?
I didn't remember his name.
I just remember his cutscene.
Wait.
That's the first Elden Lord, right?
I mean, they got crazy.
I should have stopped at the last one.
I should have...
But now, we must make merry.
I should have stopped.
I should have stopped at the first one.
The Rebels begin.
I should have stopped at the last boss.
Oh no.
Oh, Cogger ahead.
Try Warrior.
Time...
Time for...
or is it...
Hahaha.
Where's that phrase that I need?
Heh.
Time.
Hahaha.
Help me.
Oh, man.
Alright, here we go.
Uh, item.
Let's grab the item first.
Alright, here we go.
First stop, champion ahead.
Seek a strong foe.
Oh, man.
And I know he has two phases too, right?
They brought out the Halo Choir soundtrack.
You knew this was gonna be typical.
Don't worry, it'll be easy.
They even nerfed him, Doki.
It'll be fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, man.
Oh!
Okay.
I deserve that.
I...
I need...
Guys, do I got this?
Or do I need this to do a future Doki?
Maybe I should let future Doki have this...
Maybe I need...
Maybe I
should let future Doki have this...
I don't know.
Oh, my God!
Oh my god!
What the f...
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh my god, I have buddies.
I have friends.
Oh, I have friends!
No, we have friends.
How does this tiny horse able to pick him up?
Go, Alexander, go!
How is this tiny...
This tiny horse is carrying this entire game.
That's for sure.
This tiny horse is doing it all.
Gravity magic.
Holy fuck!
Go, tiny horse, go!
Look at him!
Please, help him!
He's a tiny horse!
Please, free this horse!
Oh my god!
Two people died already!
So what?
Alexander!
No!
He died.
Bro, what the fuck?
Legit!
No!
All my friends are dead!
One more friend.
I've got one more friend in.
It's not over!
I hear no...
I hear no bell!
I...
It might be over!
Oh!
Please!
I wanna be a boss too!
Alexander!
No!
No...
Okay, well now I know.
Now I know what to do.
I know what to do now.
There was...
Sorry I lied.
There was a bell.
There's the belt.
There it is.
Alexander Hamilton.
He didn't feel anything.
Look, I was going through a lot, okay?
Like, that shit was crazy.
Oh my god!
The first mission is to...
The first mission is to get over there first.
Let's try to summon as much as I can right now.
I'm trying so hard to summon.
Torrin!
Torrin's not going to make it.
Alright guys, I don't think he's going to make it, guys.
I don't want to make it.
We have one more!
One more summon!
It's the festival!
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Oh my god!
Guys, I'm not... I don't think I'm ready.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
How did he die already?
How did he die?
Please, I can't get close to him!
He's so far!
Okay.
Nice, I got out.
And
yes, let's go!
Keep whaling him!
Oh my god, where did he go?
He just disappeared!
Guys, did we do it?
Guys, I think we did it!
Guys!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH I understand how the dinosaurs went extinct, chat.
I...
I understand now.
Guys, I...
I understand why the dinosaurs died from a rock.
I get it now.
I...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I...
I get it.
I understand.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Dinosaur never... was not ready for phase two.
They were never ready for it.
Oh my god.
I just thought he would magically teleport.
I didn't think he was gonna summon the next fucking meteor.
I just thought I'll be like, ah yes, let me just wait here.
Let me just wait here for him.
Oh my god, I wrote it.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh my god, please, I'm trying to summon this guy.
Please, I'm trying to summon Alexander right now.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Holy fuck, there's one more that I have to summon.
She's literally right there.
Okay, it's fine.
It's not fine, but like, I'm coping right now.
I'm actually coping.
I'm coping so hard.
I do not feel fine.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Somebody save this horse.
He does not deserve this.
He...
Somebody please.
Somebody please save this horse.
Let him rest.
This horse needs rest.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize they can body block.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you for the heals.
Oh my god.
I'm alive.
How?
It's a miracle.
What's that?
He can summon multiple meteors now?
Holy
shit.
What do you mean there's multiple meteors?
No.
Doreen.
Please.
Message appraise.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're gonna bring them back.
Bring it back, Alexander!
Get back in there!
I hear no bell!
Oh, no.
It's fine.
They're back in it.
It's like they never died.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
I turned my back on him and I got meteored.
Never look away.
Holy fuck.
I didn't realize it was too wet.
I... I wanted to grab more summons.
I just... I just want to grab the homies.
That's it.
Let me just eat everything, guys.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I'll make it there eventually, guys.
Oh, my God.
There's the last one.
Okay.
Oh!
I got the healer, though.
I got the healer.
The healer.
No!
Heal me!
Heal me, healer!
Heal me, please!
Thank you.
Thank you for the appraisals.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate that.
It really do.
It really helps a lot.
How is this the nerf version?
What kind of hell am I in?
Oh, my God.
This poor horse.
This actual poor horse.
Holy shit.
Oh,
my God.
Someone already died.
I don't know how.
But someone's already dead.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I mean to me or me, no, I've got him.
Guys, I don't think I got him, guys.
I don't think I got him.
Oh, my God.
I'm just...
This is my worst run yet.
This is actually my worst run so far.
Holy fuck.
Oh, my God.
It's everywhere.
It's...
It's actually everywhere.
Holy fuck.
I just...
I just ate all the hits possible.
I...
I don't know how I did that.
Everything just hit me all at once.
I hit...
I just rolled into every single attack there.
I'm just here to test out my appraisals at this point.
Message was appraised.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm too scared.
Get back and get it on.
Oh, I can get on the horse now.
Thank God.
Grab him.
Get over here.
Leave.
Wait until they're all here.
Wait until the crew's here.
I'm waiting for the crew.
The crew won't show up.
Oh, thank God.
They're here.
The crew's here.
And then I missed.
Okay, that's cool.
That's cool.
That's all right.
All right.
That sounds about right.
That's...
Don't worry.
I'll hit it event...
I'll hit them eventually, guys.
Okay.
I do have to say...
The fucking cape is so disorienting sometimes.
But...
But it's so hard to hit the cape sometimes.
Okay, I will say that.
I will say that.
The cape, like, blocked everything for me.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
It's the meteor.
It's the fucking meteor.
Please.
Not me.
Oh, not me.
Thank god.
Thank god, not me.
Oh no, not me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh fuck, guys.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared to turn my...
I'm too scared to turn my back on him.
I wanna...
Woo!
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
I don't...
RACE!
Guys, guys!
Message and praise, please!
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
It went for him.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Why?!
Please.
Holy shit!
It's okay.
He's taking it all.
Oh my god.
I'm taking it all.
Oh!
Jesus!
Please!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Me and the wolfman!
We were... He died for my sins!
He actually died for my sins!
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Now look at the beautiful stars.
As I'm surrounded by my dead friends.
What happened?
I earned this.
Oh!
A red mark was made on the map.
I did it, guys!
I'm a hero!
Ray was holding all those stars while fighting you by the way!
What the fuck was he doing with all those stars?
I'm gonna have to seek water side.
Okay.
No, we don't need this right now.
Trace meters, gravity magic, big blades, doki strength, praise...
J.J.K.
Jumping.
What a sick way to...
Oh, you're alive!
The glory of the class is shared...
...by Radan...
...and you...
...and then a falling star...
...right before our eyes.
Oh!
I can't find them how Radan was holding back something...
...if that's...
Yeah!
Oh yeah, he was holding the stars!
Oh, there's less stars now!
Oh no, now we're gonna be invaded by aliens!
He was holding the aliens back!
Yay!
That's me!
That's me, guys!
I did it!
I did it, everyone!
Alright, time to...
Time to level these up...
...to like 40, right?
Am I doing it all the way to 40?
Or do I...
Or do I do like...
...one...
...dexterity?
Or two?
Alright, I'll put one in dexterity before I put...
...put it on.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's call it here.
I'm...
We made a lot of progress.
Let's call it here.
I'm... I'm okay with calling it...
...with calling it here.
We got a story boss down.
Alright.
Oh my god.
But yeah, that was fun.
Thank God...
The message of praise...
...as prop took me to the end there.
But...
Tomorrow in the morning to wake up super early for...
...the panel and the Artist Alley tour.
So...
Wow!
And I have so much work to do tonight.
Um...
But I won't be streaming until Wednesday.
So...
I'll be taking...
...Sunday, Monday, and Tuesday off...
...to recuperate.
And if I still have a brain fog...
...um...
...during...
...the week...
...during that week...
...um...
...I'm gonna do it again...
...next week...
...for Sunday, Monday, and Tuesday.
So like...
...if I still have brain fog...
...I'll continue to like...
...uh...
...like...
...rest a little bit more...
...until like...
...the brain fog leaves.
Because I'm like...
...my...
...thought process...
...is lagging a lot more.
Because usually like...
...when I talk...
...or when I yap...
...it's much more fluid.
But lately...
...I can find myself like...
...stuttering.
Like...
...my brain is actually like...
...stuttering.
It's like...
...what do I say next?
I'm like...
...this never happened before, Toki!
You've been streaming for how long?
Yeah, even now...
...I was lagging a little bit.
Because I was like...
...what do I...
...how do I say this?
What's that word again?
Um...
But yeah...
...thank you all for coming!
As always...
...everybody...
...stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you...
...stay up for me...
...head to bed.
Cause...
...you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!